So Leute, ich bin wieder da, ich hab mir gedacht, mach ich davon auch mal an.
Ich hab sonst grad nix großartiges zu tun, ich hab mir so überlegt, warum nicht noch
mal eine Runde Streams machen.
Wir machen nix super kompliziertes, wir machen auch nix mit den Servern weiter und wir programmieren
auch nix und wir gucken uns vielleicht ein paar von euren Desktops an.
Ich hab heute das Dead Space Remake gespielt, kam ja vor, keine Ahnung, zwei Wochen oder
so raus.
Ich muss sagen, mir gefällt's bisher gut, es gibt aber auch ein paar Sachen, die find
ich nicht so gut.
Auf der einen Seite ist es ganz cool, dass das Raumschiff jetzt quasi ein bisschen open
worldiger ist.
Auf der anderen Seite wusste man bei Dead Space eh schon immer nicht so genau, wo man
hinlaufen muss, deswegen gab es ja auch diesen Kompass.
Und jetzt blickt man teilweise gar nicht mehr durch.
Und ich muss auch sagen, grafisch ist es natürlich schon deutlich hübscher, als das original,
ich mein das, guck mal, das original Dead Space kam raus 2008 und das Remake jetzt 2023.
Also in 15 Jahren dazwischen, oder?
Ja, 15 Jahre, also man sieht schon, dass da 15 Jahre dazwischen sind, aber das original
Dead Space, finde ich, sieht heute immer noch relativ gut aus und das ist jetzt zwar alles
realistischer und irgendwie auch atmosphärischer auf manche Art und Weise, aber es ist auch
deutlich dunkler und Dead Space war im Original schon dunkel as fuck.
Man kann natürlich ein bisschen Helligkeitsslider rumspielen und man kann Raytracing, Belichtung
ausschalten und sowas, dann ist es nicht ganz so dunkel, aber immer noch deutlich dunkler
als das Original.
Wie gesagt, das original Dead Space war schon dunkel, aber das Remake ist teilweise einfach
nur komplett schwarz und du siehst gar nichts.
Ich finde es aber bis jetzt ganz gut, ob es 60 Euro wert ist, da kann man sich wirklich
darüber streiten, aber sie haben sich Mühe gegeben, also sie haben das Game im Endeffekt
ja mehr oder weniger komplett neu in Frostbite gebaut.
Ja dafür haben sie übrigens, also das was DICE bei Battlefield nicht hinbekommen hat,
also Frostbite Leute haben sie wohl anscheinend genug gehabt, weil das neue Dead Space Remake
ist ja in Frostbite und nicht mehr in, ich habe es ja vorhin auf Twitter geschrieben,
aber ich sage es jetzt hier im Stream auch nochmal, weil mich das echt überrascht hat.
Wusstet ihr, dass das original Dead Space von 2008 in der Tiger Woods Golf Engine ist?
Damit hätte ich nie gerechnet man, wie kommt man auf, ich hätte nie gedacht, dass die aus
einem Golfspiel Dead Space gebaut haben, aber gut, ich meine, das hat ja nicht zwangsläufig
was mit dem Spiel was am Ende rauskommt zu tun, aber es hat mich trotzdem irgendwie
gewundert.
Scheint dir der Shit damals gewesen zu sein, die Tiger Woods Golf Game Engine, ob ich so
gut finde, dass Isaac jetzt spricht im Singleplayer weiß ich gar nicht, da hat er im ersten Teil
die Klammer gehalten.
Ich fand es eigentlich ganz gut, dass Isaac kein Gesicht hatte im ersten Teil bis zum
Outro und dass er nichts gesagt hat, das ist ein bisschen oldschooliger, es ist aber auch
nicht schlecht, wie sie das im Remake gemacht haben, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass Isaac einen
zu labert oder so, ist schon okay, 60 Euro ist es vielleicht nicht wert, aber ich muss
ja mal irgendwas auf meinem Rechner spielen, was sie ein bisschen ausladen, übrigens Leute,
ich hab das Dead Space Remake, ich hab alles auf Ultra gestellt, Raytracing, Belichtung,
höchste Quality, Anti-Ellasing, alles, also höher kann man dieses Spiel nicht stellen,
wie ich es eingestellt hab und ich hab durchgängig irgendwie 200 FPS, also der neue Rechner haut
schon gut rein, ich mein mal 1080p langweilt der sich ja zu Tode mit der 4090, aber muss
man schon sagen, das läuft, das läuft.
Also 200 FPS, Dead Space ist aber auch ein dankbares Spiel, was das angeht, das besteht
ja zum größten Teil aus ganz engen Korridoren und sowas, im Endeffekt ist Dead Space ein
Spiel, was wahrscheinlich überall relativ gut laufen sollte, es gibt ja wenig größere
Areale.
Ne noch nicht, ich wollte mir einen 1440p Monitor kaufen, dann aber den OLED, das hab
ich aber letztens in Review gesehen zu diesem LG 240Hz OLED 1440p Monitor und der hat richtig
mieses Font Rendering und für jemanden wie ich, der den halben Tag auf den Texteditor
guckt oder auf den Terminal, ist natürlich schlechtes Font Rendering also eines der Sachen,
die ich wirklich gar nicht gebrauchen kann.
Ja es hat schon seine Vorteile im OLED Monitor, gerade dass es eben deutlich höheren Kontrast
hat, schwarz halt auch wirklich schwarz ist und sowas, damit würde das Dead Space Remake
wahrscheinlich nochmal eine Runde atmosphärischer aussehen, aber mieses Font Rendering kann
ich mir gar nicht geben.
Also das war für mich das Ausschlusskriterium, warum ich mir diesen Monitor nicht gekauft
hab.
Also ich hab ja schon geguckt, wo gibt's den zu kaufen, bisher gab's den ja nur vor
zu bestellen und ich werd ihn jetzt nicht kaufen, also schlechtes Font Rendering kann
ich mir einfach nicht leisten, also schlechtes Font Rendering will ich nicht, weil wie gesagt
ich gucke aufs Terminal und im Texteditor, also ich hab einen ISO hier stehen, also ich
könnt jetzt nicht weiter gucken, aber der Monitor, der auf dieser Seite hier steht, links
neben diesem Monitor, wo ich gerade am äußeren Bildschirmrand bin, das ist ein ISO, ist
schon relativ alt, aber den hab ich mir damals gekauft und kalibriert und ich muss sagen,
wenn man ein Monitor braucht, wo die Darstellung wirklich recht nah am Original ist, da sind
die ISO Dinger wirklich nicht schlecht, das ist kein Gaming Monitor, der hat nur 60Hz
und ist auch nicht der größte und ist jetzt nicht so geil, aber für Office Sachen und
Farbdarstellungen ist der ISO tatsächlich nicht schlecht, den hier, den hab ich auch
per Farbprofil mal kalibriert, da muss ich sagen, eine gute Farbdarstellung bedeutet
nicht automatisch, dass die Games, also das heißt im Endeffekt, wenn du eine Bildbearbeitung
aufmachst, da kannst du sehr gut einschätzen, wie sieht denn das am Ende aus, das bedeutet
aber nicht zwangsläufig, dass man in den Games optimal spielen kann, zum Beispiel Gegner
sichtbarkeit und sowas, also kalibriert der Monitor heißt es nicht zwangsläufig, dass
das für Games eine gute Sache ist, bei Games kann es durchaus sinnvoll sein, es beispielsweise
viel zu hell einzustellen und sowas, sodass du besser Gegner siehst und dann ist da halt
dunkles Grau, nicht dunkles Grau, sondern eher so matschiges Hellgrau, aber du siehst die
Gegner halt besser, das kann durchaus Sinn machen, aber wenn man halt möglichst echte
Farben haben will, dann nicht, welches Keyboard verwendest du auf der Arbeit, eine Ducky One
Skyline mit Numblock, mit Numpad, hier das Teil, ich like sowas von Cookies, nur dass
meine Farben, meine Tasten sind teilweise blau, die hier habe ich auf der Arbeit, Ducky
One Skyline, so sieht die aus, bisschen höher Auflösung hat sie in Real Life, ganz wichtig
Blue Switches, warum Blue Switches, weil die leiser sind, oder weswegen Blue Switches,
also ich habe glaube ich keine, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, was für Switches ich habe,
was sind denn so die default Switches braun, dann habe ich wahrscheinlich braune Switches,
aber ich habe unter Tasten, auf die ich besonders hart drauf haue, habe ich so einen kleinen
Silikonring drunter, dass die Taste nicht so oft, dass die Taste nicht so brutal laut
ist, also ich habe zum Beispiel unter Numblock, Enter, mein Enter Tasten sieht übrigens
nicht so aus, meine Enter Taste sieht so aus, kleine Enter Tasten, zack, nochmal richtig,
ja, also ich habe um Numblock so einen Silikonlock drinne, ich habe glaube ich, Control könnte
sein und Enter, ich habe auch, ich habe auch, ich habe unter paar Tasten so einen Silikonring
drunter, weil ich neige dazu beispielsweise auf den Numblock, auf Numblock Enter besonders
fest drauf zu hauen und mit dem Silikonring drunter hörst du es gar nicht mehr großartig,
du hast keine, du hast eine RGB Tastatur auf der Arbeit, doch wenn das eine gute Tastatur
ist, ach ganz ehrlich, ich persönlich würde wenig Wert darauf legen, ob meine Tastatur
professionell aussieht oder nicht, wenn das eine gute Tastatur ist und wenn die Funktionen
gut sind und man gut mit der Tastatur klarkommt, ist auch egal, außerdem ist RGB Beleuchtung
immer besser als keine RGB Beleuchtung, das haben wir ja mittlerweile gelernt, deswegen
habe ich auch RGB RAM, ich gucke zwar nicht in meinen Rechner rein, ich kann auch nicht
mal richtig in meinen Rechner reingucken, weil ich den zweiten Rechner lieber der Glastür
neben stehen habe, aber da oben kann ich so ein bisschen, ich gucke gerade ein bisschen
reingucken, aber ich habe RGB RAM, weil RGB, Skillkiller, danke für den Sub, RGB Beste,
leider was wir gerade noch anfangen, leider ist Dead Space kein all zu langes Game, was
aber auch, was heißt leider, eigentlich ist es auch ganz gut, weil es eben ein rundes
Game ist, so mit der Spiellänge und so, ich glaube ich lasse mich da im nächsten Stream
mal aus, wie mir das Remake insgesamt gefallen hat, ich mache da kein extra Video zu, das
ist schon eine Weile raus, das interessiert jetzt eh keine Saube, was ich dazu sage, aber
ich lasse mich mal im nächsten Stream ein bisschen zu aus, ob das taugt, wie gesagt
bis jetzt bin ich so, bin ich ein bisschen, ja nein, ich weiß noch nicht so genau, ob
ich das besser als das Original finde, naja, wie gesagt Leute, ich habe nichts großartiges
geplant, wir können uns jetzt noch ein paar Videos angucken, wir können ein bisschen
schwätzen, wir können uns angucken, was die Bahn so treibt, Verkehrs, ne bloß nicht,
das ist das letzte, wo ich hingehen würde, machen wir nachher auch, wir gucken uns noch
ein paar Desktops an, wir können auch mal Reddit, Unix pormen, wir können auch mal
ins offizielle Subreddit gehen und uns mal, oah, meine Augen, meine Augen, Sekunde, Sekunde,
Sekunde, es war einfach close, close, close call, alter, guck mal, Timer scheint beliebt
zu sein, nicht nur ich habe Timer gebaut, er hat auch einen Timer gebaut, hat eine einen
Kauftyp für mich, einer Klingelanlagen Erweiterung, ja, erzähl mal, also ich kann natürlich nur
was zu dem sagen, was ich bei mir habe und wenn ich es jetzt noch mal einbauen würde,
würde ich es wahrscheinlich anders machen, aber 2013 hatte ich ja noch keinen Plan von,
aber wo ziehst du die Abfalltermine, Daten in deinem Heim, der Sportär, äh, Müllmax
oder so heißt das, ja, Abfallkalender Hanau, Müllmax, von Müllmax kriege ich meine Daten
für das Dashboard, bester, bester Name, schon gesehen, an Mathe, das haben wir tatsächlich
schon mal geguckt, vor einem Jahr oder so schon, kein HTTPS, tja, was erwartet man bei irgendwelchen,
guck mal, Firefox von 2005 oder so, Testurteil, sehr gut, achso, Barrierefreiheit, ok, ich
wollte gerade sagen, Test sehr gut zugänglich, was ist das für ein Testurteil, da bekomme
ich die Sachen her, du musst mal gucken, weil, oder meinst du, welche Home Assistant, welches
Home Assistant Plugin ich verwende dafür, ich verwende, äh, Home Assistant, uuuh, das
könnte es sein, ich bin mir da nicht ganz sicher, Custom Compound, ja doch doch, ich
glaube das sind die, ja, ich glaube, ich glaube ich verwende, ich glaube ich verwende das
ja, Waste Collection Schedule, ist Müllmax von Max, ne, Leute, wie würde, ihr kennt
mich, wie würde mein Service heißen, wenn ich so einen Müllservice anbieten würde,
wie würde der heißen, der würde nicht Müllmax heißen, sondern Müllchamp, genau, oder Trashchamp
oder sowas, richtig, so sieht es aus, ihr wisst Bescheid, das wäre dann der Müllchamp
am Start, yep, Trash ist auch nicht schlecht, ja, also das Teil hier verwende ich, guck
mal, je nachdem wo du wohnst, also vielleicht, vielleicht kannst du ja so grob leaken, weil
dann könnten wir jetzt auch mal gucken, ob das unterstützt wird, aber die Chance, dass
das unterstützt wird, ist relativ hoch, guck mal, die unterstützen hier mehr oder weniger,
gefühlt ganz Deutschland, und nicht nur ganz Deutschland, die unterstützen sogar Australia
und sogar die USA, sogar Kekona, kommt noch ein bisschen, vielleicht, vielleicht demnächst
tatsächlich ein bisschen, ja, heute nicht, heute bin ich zu kaputt, aber irgendwie großartig
was zu machen, für was ist das gut, Müllkalender, dass man weiß, wann die Müllabfuhr kommt,
guck, da kann man in seinen Home Assistant zum Beispiel, es gibt ja auch fertige, ja,
es gibt ja auch fertige Karten, wo man sich so in so ein Dashboard, ich glaube ich habe
mein Dashboard selbst gebaut dafür, also da kann man in seinem Home Assistant Dashboard
sich anzeigen lassen, wann der Müll kommt, was ich ganz praktisch finde, weil dadurch,
dass es in der Heimautomatisierung drinne ist, hat man da nicht nur die Information
auf dem Dashboard stehen, sondern könnte sich zum Beispiel auch morgens, wenn man, sagen
wir mal, montags kommt, wird hier der Allesmüll abgeholt oder die gelbe Tonne, montags wird
die gelbe Tonne abgeholt und du musst sie noch rausstellen, aber du verlässt montags
das Haus, weil du mal zur Abwechslung auf die Arbeit fahren musst, dann könnte deine
Heimautomatisierung dir zum Beispiel noch eine Message schicken, wenn du die Tür aufmachst
am Haus, weil das kriegst du ja dann auch mit, du kannst ja dann sagen, ok, es ist Montag,
es ist ein Arbeitstag, es ist vor 6 Uhr oder vor 7 Uhr oder was auch immer und dann kannst
du dir dann noch eine Push-Message aufs Handy schicken lassen, so nach dem Motto, Achtung,
du verlässt das Haus, denk dran die Mülltonne rauszustellen und ich denke, das würde einigen
schon helfen, wenn sie sich das hinvor hätten und dann würden sie es nicht vergessen.
Kann man alles machen, die Möglichkeiten sind ja nahezu unbegrenzt, wenn man die Daten erstmal
in seiner Heimautomatisierung drin hat, das ist ja immer das wichtigste, dass man dann
auch was findet, was zu einem passt, es bringt ja meistens gar nichts, das habe ich ja schon
oft gesagt, wenn es ums Thema Heimautomatisierung geht, es bringt gar nichts so anzufangen wie
viele Leute anfangen und zwar viele Leute fangen mit RGB Beleuchtung an und ich glaube
RGB Beleuchtung, ohne sich vorher Gedanken zu machen, ist wirklich das blödeste Einstiegsthema
in die Heimautomatisierung, denn man stellt sich es sehr cool vor, aber am Ende ist es
zu 90% überflüssig, die Leute stellen sich das dann mega nice vor, auf der Arbeit hat
mir ein Kollege erzählt so nachdem, oh jetzt wird Haus renoviert und er will sich überall
Philips Hue Dinger an die Decke machen und sowas, die gibt es ja wohl auch zum fester
einbauen und sowas, das ist dann richtig nice, dann hat er im Flur dann so coole Steuerungsmöglichkeiten
mit dem Licht, da habe ich ihm auch gesagt, geh nochmal in dich, ob du das wirklich machen
willst, weil erstens ist das Philips Hue Zeug eigentlich unverschämt teuer, lässt sich
glücklicherweise mehr oder weniger in alles integrieren, ist aber unverschämt teuer, aber
der nächste Punkt ist, die meisten Leute überschätzen das, also gerade Leute, die mit Heimautomatisierung
anfangen und mit Beleuchtung einsteigen, die überschätzen grandios, was sie brauchen,
die denken sich dann, also ich brauche im Flur mindestens 6 kleine RGB Lampen im Schlafzimmer,
im Wohnzimmer, vielleicht noch unten irgendwie eine Leiste an der Treppe, bla bla bla bla,
so und im Endeffekt läuft es dann da rauf, ein was ungefähr so, was ist denn das, warte,
das müssen wir uns gleich angucken, klar, ich sag erst nochmal, ich sag erst nochmal
fertig, fertig, weil ich sage, sonst habe ich wieder vergessen und das wollte ich jetzt
genau, also und dann bauen sie sich das alles ein und dann sind sie enttäuscht, weil es
sie eigentlich gar nicht so sehr bringt, es gibt zwei Problematiken, wenn man wenig Ahnung
von Heimautomatisierung hat und anfängt mit RGB Beleuchtung bzw. sein Einstieg macht mit
Beleuchtung, so, das erste woran man denken muss ist, wenn man weiterhin einen manuellen
Schalter haben möchte an der Wand, so zum Licht ein und ausschalten, dann sind manchmal
smarte Lampen nicht das Richtige, weil wenn man den Schalter ein und ausschaltet, funktioniert
die smarte Lampe nicht mehr, ist ja logisch, weil die smarte Lampe hat dann keinen Strom
mehr wenn man den Schalter ausgeschaltet hat und die meisten haben keinen Bock ihr Licht
über die App auszuschalten, also entweder brauchst du dann einen Schalter, der quasi
gar nicht wirklich schaltet, sondern quasi nur als Trigger fungiert mit einer Heimautomatisierung
und Steuerung und dann die Lampe ein und ausschaltet, das geht oder wenn du wirklich einen echten
Schalter haben willst, kannst du auch so unterputz einen Relay hinbauen oder ein Relay, wie
ich ja sagen soll, weil die Leute sagen, ich soll das deutscher aussprechen, Relay soll
ich sagen, Relay, ich sag aber Relay, weil mir irgendwie die englische Aussprache lieber
ist, da könnte man sich zum Beispiel den Shelly oder sonst was drunter bauen, Relay
und dann hat man auch schon alles, sondern das nächste ist, die Leute überschätzen was
sie brauchen bei RGB Beleuchtung, äh generell bei Smart Home Beleuchtung, viele denken,
RGB Lampe überall hin, es ist nicht zwangsläufig die beste Variante überall eine RGB Lampe
hin zu hängen, also es gibt mehrere Stufen was die Leute brauchen für ihre Beleuchtung,
wie gesagt das erste ist irgendwie die Möglichkeit Smart ein und aus zu schalten, am besten so
dass man am Schalter ein und ausschalten kann, per Heimautomatisierung, Steuerung, Automatisierung
ein und ausschalten kann und auch manuell getriggert übers Handy ein und ausschalten
kann, so, das ist das erste was sie brauchen, der nächste Schritt ist, nach ein und ausschalten
können, ist DIMBA und nicht DIMBA und da fängt es eigentlich schon an, an vielen Stellen
ist es gar nicht so wirklich notwendig, dass es DIMBA ist, da reicht publisches ein und
ausschalten fast schon aus, aber ok DIMBA ist ne gute Sache, kann man zum Beispiel anpassen
wie hell leuchtet ein der Kram im Flur an, wenn man gerade aufgestanden ist und so was,
DIMBA ist meistens auch noch sinnvoll und DIMBA sind eigentlich alle smarten Klübieren,
wobei es keine Klübieren sind, man muss ja glaube ich ganz offiziell sagen Leuchtmittel,
aber ich finde das Wort so bescheuert, ich sage weiter Klübieren, so DIMBA ist sinnvoll
und der nächste Schritt ist, also nach DIMBA, also der nächste Schritt inkludet immer alle
vorangegangenen Schritte, wenn ich das sage, also das erste ist ein ausschaltbar, das nächste
ist DIMBA, der nächste Schritt ist ein ausschaltbar DIMBA und Farbtemperatur regelbar, Farbtemperatur
regelbar ist in der Regel so, dass du quasi den Rotanteil, den Rotanteil steuern kannst,
quasi ob es blaulicher weiß weiß blaulicher ist oder ob das weiß rötlicher ist, so das
ist die nächste Stufe und die letzte Stufe ist RGB, dass du wirklich alle Farben machen
kannst, also ein ausschaltbar, DIMBA, Temperatur und alle Farben, warum man sich da drüber
Gedanken machen muss ist, RGB Lampen sind mit Abstand die teuersten und meistens überhaupt
nicht notwendig, weil du kaum irgendwo RGB wirklich haben willst, wo willst du RGB haben,
das einzige wo mir es wirklich einfällt, wo es wahrscheinlich die meisten Leute machen
wenn sie die Möglichkeit dafür haben ist vielleicht im Wohnzimmer, wo da Fernseh steht,
dass man nämlich zum Beispiel, wobei selbst da die Farbtemperatur eigentlich meistens
ausreicht, aber vielleicht wollen manche besonders coole Atmosphäre haben beim Filmgucken und
so, Wohnzimmer, ok, verstehe ich, vielleicht möchte es auch noch einer im Schlafzimmer,
weil ihn das irgendwie in Stimmung bringt, wenn es dann pink oder rot oder was auch immer
ist, gachi Bustime, vielleicht bringt das die Leute in Wallung im Schlafzimmer wenn
die RGB Beleuchtung haben, ok, macht auch noch Sinn, aber ansonsten, ich weiß es gibt
so Designer Fetischisten, die sagen wir brauchen die ganze Wohnung einheitlich irgendwie so
ein cooles Farbdesign, so nach dem Motto, wenn ich irgendwie Salat mache in der Küche dann
soll es grün sein wie im Garten oder sowas, ja das ist gut, wenn man so abgedrehte Anforderungen
hat, dann macht RGB vielleicht doch Sinn, aber das wichtigste was ich am Anfang gesagt
habe, gilt ja nach wie vor, da muss man sich Gedanken drüber machen, das heißt wenn jemand
diese Anforderungen hat, ja meinetwegen, oder wenn einer zum Beispiel im Bad oder die Dusche
gehen will, irgendwie Meeresrauschen oder Wasserfallplätschern aus den Lautsprechern
drinnen haben möchte, plus irgendwie dann cooles blaues RGB Licht sowie irgendwie was
was ich in der Höhle am Wasser falle, ja dann bau dir halt RGB ins Badezimmer ein meinetwegen,
ok, aber die meisten Leute brauchen überhaupt kein RGB und wenn dann nur an ganz speziellen
Stellen, das heißt die meisten Leute wollen eigentlich was was man ordentlich ein und
ausschalten kann, sowohl an einem Schalter als auch über die Heimautomatisierung, Steuerung
als auch über das Handy und das nächste was die meisten Leute wollen ist DIMBA, so entweder
stimmt der Farbton von Anfang an und dann reicht DIMBA oder man möchte ein bisschen
die Farbatmosphäre ändern, dann reicht DIMBA und Farbtemperatur Anpassung, fertig, ich
habe es jetzt gesehen beim Kollege auf der Arbeit, der hat mir auch erzählt sie renn
will den und dann machen sie überall Philips Hue hin und super geil und RGB, ich habe ihn
auch gefragt, bist du dir wirklich sicher, dass du überall RGB machen musst, also erst
ist das Schweine teuer und du wirst es wahrscheinlich nicht benutzen, außerdem kannst du dir dann
vielleicht auch was anderes als Philips Hue überlegen, du wirst es wahrscheinlich nicht
benutzen, warum willst du bei einer Lampe die sagen wir mal an der Eingangstür ist,
sagen wir mal du hast einen Eingangsbereich in der Wohnung und da hast du dann so eine
Decke verteilt, vielleicht so 3 Lampen oder eine große Lampe oder was auch immer, warum
braucht das RGB, DIMBA, das lasse ich mir irgendwo noch gefallen aber eigentlich reicht
in dem Bereich auch schon Publiches an und ausschaltbar aus und das spart Geld, das spart
richtig viel Geld, wenn man einfach sagt ok ich habe realisiert ich brauche nicht bei
jeder Lampe RGB und vielleicht kommt man sogar auf die glorreiche Idee, dass einen zum größten
Teil ein und ausschaltbar reicht und dann kann man richtig viel Geld sparen, weil dann
braucht man gar keine smarten Lampen, sondern kann sich zum Beispiel ein Shelly oder sowas
in den Schalter unter Putz in den Schalter bauen und dann hat man die Möglichkeit jede
x beliebige Lampe am Schalter einen auszuschalten und über die Heimautomatisierungsteuerung.
Ja so sieht es aus, so viel zum Thema RGB Beleuchtung daheim, ich hätte gar nicht gedacht,
dass ich mir 10 Minuten drüber auslassen kann, was war das hier, was hat der Dude am Start?
Eigentlich eine coole Sache, aber in Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass du alle 14 Tage oder so,
na gut ne, das stimmt da gar nicht, dadurch, dass das unterschiedliche Tonnen sind, sind
schon mehr, aber na gut, es ist vielleicht leichtes Overkill, zumal du jetzt überall
im Hof Schienen verlegt hast, was auch nervig sein kann, aber eine coole Idee ist es ja
schon irgendwo, stimmt, außerdem gibt es auch extra Dimmer, wo man die normalen Lampen
mit dimmen kann, richtig, dann steht die falsche Tonne auch da, ja, so ja genau, wie sieht
es mit der Klingelanlage jetzt aus, da wollte ich glaub auch etwas zu sagen, wir können
darüber reden, dass C++ weird ist und unendlich Loops undcefined behaviors sein können, weil
C++ ist eigentlich nur weird, dass nix mehr einem weird vorkommen muss, weil alles weird
weird champ so und der chat hat eine klingel gepostet alles klar so was ist das da gong
funk relay klingeltaster funk klingeltaster das verdrahtet und das links ist was also
das netzteil aber ist das von irgendeinem speziellen hersteller oder ist das einfach
so ganz normales hutschienen aufsteck dingsbums das einzige was ich mich jetzt frage ist moment
ach dir geht es nur um die klingel du willst gar keine gegensprechanlage oder sowas haben ja
dann ist doch easy dann dann wo ist das problem doch eigentlich recht sinn ist recht sinnig aus
ach hier habe eine bestehende anlage und möchte an eine tür einen funktaster anbringen der mir
am schaltrad ein funk relay auslöst welches parallel zum vertragen klingeltaster durchschaltet
auch elektronik stellt ich sehe schon
du willst damit quasi den gong gongen lassen oder sehe ich das richtig also dein ziel ist
dass du mit dem schalter den gong gongen lassen kannst mit dem da mit dem da also das du mit
dem klingeltaster den gong gong gongen lassen kannst ok verstehe das sieht doch jetzt so
eigentlich relativ sinnig aus oder chat das sieht doch eigentlich ganz sinnvoll aus ok
ich kann also wirklich wirklich zu dem setup kann ich dir nicht so viel sagen ich kann dir
nur eine sache erzählen von von meiner tür gegensprechanlage dieses ganze diese ganze
tür klingel geschichte das ist wirklich schwarze magie da merkst du das ist technik seit 150
jahren und hat ganz viel verwirrende dinger zum beispiel ist es bei meiner klingel so dass die
die das ist nicht dc bei mir das ist alles ac und die machen dann solche sachen wie wenn es
klingelt geht die spannung auf 30 volt wenn einer den telefonhörer abhebt auf 27 volt und wenn
er wieder aufgelegt wurde auf 15 volt und anhand dessen erkennen beispielsweise auch die telefone
wann sie klingeln müssen und war nicht sehr sehr weird alles sehr sehr also aber ich finde
dein plan sieht doch eigentlich sinnvoll aus also ich vermute mal dein klingeltaster ist
nicht der offizielle für diesen gong sondern halt was was hier mit dein gepaart ist doch jetzt
eigentlich ganz sinnvoll aus so zu machen aber wirklich plan davon habe ich nicht
ach dir fehlt die hardware dazu was du meinst was man dann nehmen kann
du brauchst ich weiß ja nicht was du hast du kannst jeden xp also wie ich wie ich das machen
würde also ich würde es ich würde es wahrscheinlich relativ einfach machen
ich würde einen meiner bestehenden also eben gut das ding hier brauche ich eine stromversorgung
eventuell kannst du die gleiche stromversorgung nehmen davon schon wenn es das aushält die
dinger brauchen ja meistens so gut wie nix da kannst du ein jelly nehmen die lassen sich per
12 volt dc glaube ich betreiben und für den funktaster ist halt die frage was was für funk
sie du kannst in zig b button nehmen und billigen es soll ja auch eine weile halten ja kannst
billigen zig b button nehmen zum beispiel wenn du das hast oder einen dieser fix und fertigen
klingel schalter dass man das dann irgendwie per funkt abgreift keine ahnung da muss ich
ehrlich sagen da habe ich das habe ich noch nicht geguckt da weiß ich jetzt so spontan nichts
warum bist du eigentlich so besessen von zent flume du kommst jeden stream rein
genau das das was ich sagen wollte im endeffekt das kannst du auch machen aber wenn jemand
auf den ein und ausschalter drückt ist auch der esp aus je nachdem wo das angeschlossen
ist oder die lampe ist aus ich sehe schon der chat hat wieder genauer vorstellung wie es
aussehen soll wenn tesla besitzer ab kommender woche beziehungsweise spätestens 20.2 dann
geht es los mit dem automatischen laderoboter ja das video war geil mit dem automatischen
laderoboter hast du den falls du das verraten willst hast du den gekauft hast du den geliest
hast du dir den mal irgendwie gemietet kurz oder auf welche auf welche wege hast du den
tesla gekauft und welchen ach so jahre finanzierung ok also willst du den länger behalten oder
willst du den nur ein zwei jahre fahren und weg so sechs jahre ok model 3 long range was
ist denn long range bei denen was was was fahren die denn so wie weit kann man damit maximal
fahren also ich mit meinem fiat das weiß ich mit meinem fiat komme ich so maximal 290 kilometer
weit aber auch nur wenn er bis zum anschlag voll ist und es nicht zu kalt ist
kann ich euch was zu erzählen ich habe zwar kein tesla aber ich habe ja auch ein elektroauto
also bei meinem fiat ist ein zur werkstatt transport service mit dabei zwei jahre zwei
jahre im kaufpreis und danach kann man den irgendwie für frag mich nicht 60 euro im
jahr oder so verlängern wenn man das will da hast du du hast sogar im auto ein knopf
da kannst du das mal angenommen du hast platten reifen und sitzt im auto und hast keinen bock
was selbst zu machen drückst du auf den knopf und dann wirst du mit der hotline verbunden
alles im auto über die gegensprecheranlage und kannst ihnen sagen hier ich stehe da und
da und dann bringen die dann auto dann bringen die dann auto in die werkstatt rufen den
taxi und fahre nicht heim und dann wieder ja naja aber 180 kilometer ist doch ein bisschen
bisschen viel
ich
das was mit herr der ringe zu tun ach ja warum willst du warum willst du den craft wie sam
und frodo getravelt sind ich mein jeder wie er will aber warum ich will dich nicht davon
abhalten die webseite runterzuladen aber willst du das ausdrucken oder über das bett hängen
oder war was ist der sinn sich das runterzuladen was dann den use case wie man so schön sagt
will ich bild speichern untermachen
mit taking the hobbits zu eisen gar leute ich bin ja generation vor harry potter ja bei mir
war es herr der ringe ich war zwar nicht so der mega ultra hardcore fan also ich habe nie
beispielsweise die extended edition im kino im triple also ich habe nie die komplette trilogie
im kino als extended edition irgendwie elf stunden oder so am stück geguckt das muss
nicht sein aber die filme und die zeit damals war schon nice wie zufrieden bist du eigentlich
mit deinem vier bis jetzt ziemlich es gibt wenig zu meckern dran was gibt es denn zu
meckern lass mal kurz in mich gehen was könnte ich meckern an meinem vier
dass ich die hintere tür nicht so oft braucht wie gedacht vielleicht dass die lüftung also
von der klimaanlage beziehungsweise von der heizung dass die sich immer auf stufe vier
stellt wenn man in automatik modus geht und wieder raus und dann auf vier bleibt das fackt
mich auch ein bisschen ab das k play sich ganz ganz vereinzelt man nicht nicht fast
drei verbindet kommt aber wirklich nicht oft vor dass man nicht so viel das ist im vergleich
zum direkten vorgänger also ich hatte vorher opel agila von 2001 das im vergleich zu dem
ein bisschen weniger sicht ist aus dem fenster also ich sehe weniger der rückspiegel ist
auch ziemlich kacke man sieht da man sieht dadurch auch nicht wirklich großartig was
aber man hatte zum glück eine kamera also wenn ich nah an der ampel zum beispiel stande
habe ich beim agila überhaupt keine probleme gehabt die direkt über mir zu sehen beim
fiat geht das manchmal nicht also nicht wenn ich normal sitze wenn man sich vorbeugt guckt
dann geht es so ansonsten gibt es noch irgendwas was mir großartig auf den keks geht ladegeschwindigkeit
geht voll in ordnung gerade mit dem ladegerät an der wand jetzt ja gut eine sache das lag
aber an mir dass ich den reifen kaputt gefahren habe habe ich euch ja schon erzählt gewichts
update hat sich nichts getan weder groß nach oben noch groß nach unten dass ich mein reifen
kaputt gefahren habe und die felge angekratzt hat ansonsten gibt es eigentlich wenig zu
meckern muss ich so fast mehr zu spontan kratz einfeld also ich bin da eigentlich recht
zufrieden mit ich würde mir den wieder kaufen schon da ist ja auch mit elektroauto an sich
bin ich auch zufrieden also ich finde das sehr angenehm dass man nicht mehr tanken gehen
muss man muss aufladen muss in hof fahren anstöpseln ist mir aber viel ist mir lieber
also in die tankstelle zu fahren die reichweiten problematik ist für mich kein problem weil
ich eh nicht so lang fahr das weiteste was ich glaube ich mit dem auto je gefahren bin
ist vor ein paar tagen zu meinem vater der wohnt ungefähr so 35 40 kilometer weg einfach
und das war überhaupt kein problem ich hatte dann am ende glaube ich noch 68 prozent oder
sowas 65 65 wobei ich kann mal meine heim automatisierung gucken wie viel gerade drauf
ist 63 prozent 63 prozent wie viel kilometer ich im jahr fahre kann ich hier gar nicht
so genau sagen aber ich könnte hochrechnen weil ich habe in meinem smart home auch den
kilometer zahn den den kilometer stand insgesamt und von reset zu reset keine ahnung genau
ich kann ich könnte gucken sage ich dir nächstes jahr wie viel es ist ich fahre mehr ich fahre
mehr ich fahre auf jeden fall mehr als noch mit dem alten weil es mit dem auto mehr bock
macht höchstgeschwindigkeit habe ich auch zum ersten mal ausprobiert vor zwei tagen
höchstgeschwindigkeit ist so um die 150 schon kilometer habe ich habe ich vorgestern mal
auf der autobahn ausprobiert also ich kann jetzt da nicht wirklich mit den richtig fetten
kisten mithalten aber bei allem davor ist er halt auch mega zackig ja also auch von
der beschleunigung ja ist schon schon ziemlich vor gut wobei man aber sagen muss ich meine
das ist kein vergleich zu meinem agila wenn der agila über 100 gefahren ist hast du gedacht
er fällt gleich auseinander falsches falsches dinge da fällt gleich auseinander und wenn
er mit dem 450 fährt da merkt er gar kein ding funktioniert ohne probleme aber so wirklich
wohl fühlen tut sich tut man sich da nicht und das auto sich auch nicht bei 150 die lenkung
ist auch ein bisschen zu leichtgängig bei diesen geschwindigkeiten also da muss ich
ganz genau aufpassen wie kann man beim ascii aquarium im hintergrund bearbeiten gar nicht
das ascii aquarium kommt so wie es ist es ist jetzt nicht so dass das lenkrad nur anpusten
muss und du liegst quasi im graben ne ne aber ich finde es ist bei bei so hohen geschwindigkeiten
fast schon ein bisschen zu leichtgängig empfiehren aber im großen und ganzen wie gesagt ich
würde es mir ich würde mir das wieder ich würde mir den wieder kaufen also bis jetzt
bis jetzt bin ich da sehr zufrieden mit
das stimmt weget leht einfach nur das html runter also wenn das java script ist das habe
ich jetzt gar nicht geguckt aber das kann durchaus sein wenn das java script ist also
wenn die seite quasi nicht so ausgeliefert wird wie was du gepostet hast wo wo ist sam
und frodo ich habe schon wieder vergesst ich sehe es schon wieder nicht wo ist es ok weget
weget ah ja hier das ist java script ja dann kannst du das mit weget nicht runterladen
das funktioniert nicht weget was dir weget runter lädt ist folgendes das lädt dir weget
runter aber keine dynamischen inhalte weget weget macht kein java script oder sowas ist
genau wie der chat sagt das ist richtig wenn du das haben willst gibt es ein paar andere
gibt es paar andere möglichkeiten was du machen kannst da kommst du mit weget nicht weit
muss man kurz runter scrollen ja das kann sein dass es mit runter lädt aber weget führt
garantiert kein kein java script aus den rennen hat irgendwelche grafen
also das das funktioniert nicht was du machen kannst ist du kannst sowas wie playwright
oder puppeteer oder was wie ist das was man früher verwendet hat für browser automatisierung
selenium kannst du verwenden da gibt es bestimmt auch fix und fertige tools da kannst du quasi
die browser fernsteuern und dir screenshots von seiten machen lassen das ist das ist
ganz nice dass das geht da gibt es tools dafür und ich bin mir relativ sicher da gibt es
wahrscheinlich auch fix und fertige command line tools dass es nicht selbst programmiert
wirst av oder av fox ich habe keine ahnung wie man das ausspricht aber dankeschön für
den prime sub afox oder sowas manche haben sie nicht zum aussprechen gemacht also gehen
tut das so habe ich irgendwas vergessen gewichts ab denn wie gesagt gibt es nichts neues ne
bordstein proof war meine felge echt nicht wobei die felge ist nicht kaputt gegangen
es ist nur ein bisschen ein bisschen gekratzt und der reifen kaputt gegangen aber ich war
ja auch blöd ich meine warum musste ich denn die das fenster ab putzen in der kurve und
dann nicht richtig gucken ja selbst schuld was also ok hast du den fiat hast du den fiat
geleast wenn ja darf ich nein habe ich nicht habe den tatsächlich gekauft wo prime die
prime subs haben quasi mein fiat bezahlt weil da muss ich ganz schön viele prime subs
bekommen ok
alles klar av fox aha aneah fox ok da wäre ich nicht drauf gekommen da wäre ich wirklich
nicht drauf gekommen so leute kommen wir gucken uns doch irgendwas an bevor bett geteilt
lass mal lass mal ganz kurz das offizielle unix porn subreddit mal kurz durch scrollen
ob es da irgendwas cooles gibt so der typ hat notifications gebaut und ein timer und feiert
sich dafür ab pogo mega ah sekunde eins eins muss jetzt leute leute wir hatten wir hatten
es lange nicht mehr wir hatten es lange nicht mehr
die wussten halt null für was sie da überhaupt was aufnehmen
ich glaube das ist sogar noch länger als elf jahre her oder wobei 2012 kann sein doch doch
das 2012 kann gut sein mega upload also so catchy song ist es ja schon
ja das war noch zeiten 2012 da haben es die leute nach tuba geschritten ob
ob xbox was ist playstation it's a hit
das machen sie immer noch aber nicht so wie 2012 2012 war shit ne gay station versus shitbox
oder wix box versus gay station okay genug mega upload jetzt
muss das muss jetzt mal wieder sein gibt es überhaupt noch share house davon ich habe
keine ahnung ich habe ewig keine mehr benutzt jetzt legit no cup ich habe keine ahnung
was es dazu also mega gibt es noch ja das weiß ich früher früher gab es noch die ogs
erinnern sich rapid share und rapid share hat damals den gesamten shit der content industrie
abbekommen weil sie einer der ersten waren erinnert sich noch jemand rapid share gibt
es das überhaupt noch okay nepster nepster war ja noch früher nepster und audio galaxy
falls ich da jemanden auch dran erinnert für für mp3 ist und so was das war das war echt
das war aber wird das war noch viel viel vor mega upload das war eher 1999 rum oder so
was nepster gibt es ja heute noch aber das ist irgendwie so ein relativ unbedeutender
streaming service glaube ich mittlerweile würdest du ultra weit oder eher zwei monitore
nehmen ich persönlich mag lieber zwei monitore das ist aber wahrscheinlich große geschmackssache
und abhängig vom schreibtisch und wie man es gerne hätte also ich persönlich mag zwei
monitore lieber wobei man sagen muss man kann ja auch viele große breite besonders
breite monitore haben ja zwei eingänge die man parallel voneinander verwenden kann also
dann glaube ich hast ja quasi schon zwei monitore aber ich mag trotzdem zwei monitore lieber
spotify hatte noch nie alles spotify hat nur sehr viel aber spotify war nicht alles
so lass mal kurz reinschauen also was machen was machen die tuts hier dennis auf unix-porn
der hat einen timer programmiert der über notification da oben eingeblendet wird ok
nice da feiert er sich jetzt für ab hyperland fancy warm color setup ok color color setup
was hat geiler screenshot alter richtig gut das sieht man ja was richtig drauf und wenn
hier ist der screenshot doch größer als hier ok der hat der hat mist verlinkt der dude
der tüber mist verlinkt aber ich sehe die weeps sind wieder am start arch by the way
es ist der einzig wahre mensch was hat der typ hier gemacht einzig wahre desktop arch
by the way was sonst ok äußerst minimalistisch arch x monad dass das über dass das jemand
verwendet ist das nicht in haskell sieht halt nahm teile window manager aus dwm new rice
old idea outdated was ist das für ein shit warum ist warum ist reddit wieder so kacke
rot und schwarz und bunt also ganz ehrlich die farbgebung gefällt mir persönlich nicht
bspwm sag mal gibt es hier in unix-porn irgendwelche leute die normale des drops verwenden also
ich weiß ich darf nichts sagen ich verwende auch in teilen window manager aber irgendwas
was für 99 prozent der weltbevölkerung normal aussieht was ist das hier eigentlich für
eine platzverschwendung was ist das hier für eine platzverschwendung man äh ne ne ne die
verschwenden gerne platz oder ich meine niemand jetzt mal seriously niemand hat doch wirklich
ok reddit ist wieder mal richtig abspacke niemand hat doch wirklich so seine fenster angeordnet
das ist doch nur dass es cool aussieht a xf ce ok mal einer der klassischen klassischen
desktop hat ok ich habe wirklich keinen plan was mit reddit abgeht warum das nicht richtig
verlinkt da muss ich sagen das finde ich tatsächlich ganz ganz hübsch farblich gemacht von ihm
halt auch wieder komplette platzverschwendung warum ist hier links nix aber gut das ist
halt zum zeigen weil es cool aussieht das ist im prinzip wirklich nur zum flexen genau
sonst nix ja wir haben sway öfters getestet und ich komme zu dem schluss dass wayland
in a vm leider nicht benutzbar ist gescheit sollte das mal irgendwann usable sein wenn
ich es auch wieder ausprobieren aber die letzten male war es komplett unbrauchbar in a vm
du brauchst i3 i3 gaps nicht mehr du bist nicht informiert du bist outdated overrated
jebaited i3 gaps ist mittlerweile gemercht in i3 und braucht man nicht mehr als extra
fork war korrekt ja dann ok dann lass ich mir es gefällt das stimmt das ist der sinn
von unix porn flexen mit seinem desktop auf eine art und weise wie man ihn wahrscheinlich
täglich gar nicht verwendet dafür ist es gedacht und uns um kommentare abzugreifen
auf reddit wie toll das aussieht und hast du deine falls irgendwie oh wie hast du das
gemacht ja klar natürlich sehe ich gucke ich mir die an
man kann die oberfläche bestimmt noch ein bisschen cooler
und einheitlicher semen als ich das gemacht habe
aber mal der vergleich leute ja das ist das ist so wie es bei mir aktuell aussieht und
ich habe gar keine ahnung wie mache ich eigentlich die standard i3 status ich glaube macht man
einfach hier i3 status rein so sieht es standardmäßig aus falls es funktioniert
so sieht i3 standardmäßig aus seriously da finde ich aber meins deutlich angenehmer
als das ne guck mal zum vergleich das versus das da gefällt mir meins aber besser
standard i3 hat auch hier nicht die eigens und so was und und standard i3 hat die hat
die leiste glaube ich sogar unten
wisst ihr ich mag leiste oben in windows mag ich es überhaupt nicht aber unter i3 habe
ich gerne leiste oben so so sind da die geschmäcker unterschiedlicher
das stimmt wohl aber ist auch bisschen wissenschaft für sich also mir hat es gereicht mein prompt
zu customisieren da brauche ich nicht noch polybar customisieren ich habe ja quasi das
vorgefertigte sieben genommen habe die farben ein bisschen umgebaut hat noch ein paar sachen
eingefügt und hat einen zweizeiligen prompt rausgemacht und ich muss sagen ich bin damit
echt zufrieden hat was vor allem dass es jetzt auch die dotnet versionen anzeigt ob
das ob man in einem git repo ist in welchem branchen man ist ob man uncommitted changes
drin hat und so was finde ich sehr nice standardmäßig in diesem preset gar nicht so drinnen gewesen
hat was und das ist auch der grund warum ich einen zweizeiligen prompt rausgemacht habe
weil guckt mal ich habe schon den halben bildschirm voll mit prompt ich will jetzt nicht da irgendwo
tippen ich will hier tippen außerdem hat man genug platz heutzutage kann man durch
einen zweizeiligen prompt machen gar kein ding weiß ich wie ihr das seht seid ihr eher ein
zeit ein zeiliger zweizeilige prompt fans was habt ihr lieber also ich habe jahrelang schon
zweizeilige prompt nachdem ich früher fast nur ein zeilige benutzt habe 2 1 3 3 zeilen was
was ok 3 zeilen das interessiert mich jetzt tatsächlich für was benutzt du die dritte
zeile oder hast du es einfach nur geschrieben just for fun du hast eine zeile nur für die
uhrzeit ok das ist ganz schön overkill ich meine man kann die urzeit einfach dahinschreiben
beziehungsweise man kann auch einfach oben auf die uhr gucken na gut wenn man die uhrzeit
des ausgeführten kommandos sehen will ok extra zeile für uhrzeit ja jeder jeder was
er für was er mag heute ich merke es mir kratzt ein bisschen im hals wahrscheinlich weil ich
heute morgen schon so viel geschwätzt habe ich habe hier morgen schon dreieinhalb stunden
gestreamt und jetzt und jetzt auch schon wieder eine stunde vielleicht sollte ich mal sprechtraining
oder gesangstraining oder sowas besuchen wo man lernt wie man ordentlich ordentlich seine
stimme benutzt mehr als vier stunden vier stunden plus am tag da muss man dann bestimmt
anders sprechen so quasi so weniger weniger ohne ohne so richtig so ohne stimme einsatz
so mehr so so entspannt und ja keine ahnung keine ahnung wie ein stimmtraining aussieht
ist das powerlevel 10k nein das ist starship guck da starship falls irgendjemand sich dafür
interessiert wie meine config ist ich habe es mittlerweile gepusht da guckt vor zwei
tagen habe ich drüber gepusht falls irgendjemand die alten dot files sucht von früher die
auch in dem repo waren die sind hier die sind hier hier sind meine neun und hier ist die
starship tommel tommel weil written in russ blazingly fast und so ihr wisst schon ist meine
mein prompt man kann ja die die eigens im browser gar nicht anzeigen was macht t max
gar nichts habe ich nicht mehr benutze ich nicht mehr bei mir lokal benutze ich nur noch
remote auf dem server und da fast jede session aber lokal habe ich nicht mehr lokal mache
ich das jetzt rein mit dem terminal ohne t max kein temox mehr ausgetemoxed guck mal
jetzt habe ich auch einen dreizeitigen prompt leute easy einfach easy dreizeitigen prompt
gemacht sieht aber ganz schön scheiße aus mein dreizeitiger prompt oder bleiben wir
mal lieber so
ist es eigentlich schwer bei e3 die dünne border beim ziehen zu treffen was denn das
hier oder was du musst den border nicht treffen du musst ein mod key festhalten dann kannst
du überall ziehen alter die noobs wieder im chat man was ist da los ich dachte ihr habt
was gelernt bei mir du musst einfach den mod key halten da kannst du da kannst du
resize wo du willst guck also hier da hier kann ich resize noch wenn ich den mod key
gedrückt habe also mod key ist halt bei dir entweder windows taster oder alt höchstwahrscheinlich
kannst du resize und im terminal kann ich auch resize aber das jetzt vom terminal nicht
von e3 ich hoffe ich hoffe es hat dir was gebracht und du kannst jetzt einfach resize
ja das stimmt wohl aber resize und solche sachen es gibt ein paar dinger ne ne ne mag
ich nicht habe ich mag ich so wenig in meiner e3 konfig dass ich das tatsächlich rausgenommen
habe aus der konfig ich kann ich habe resize aus der konfig ausgeschmissen also resize mit
tastatur habe ich nie verwendet
aber siehst du so ist es nicht mehr so schwierig den den border zu treffen
bei dir geht das nicht was hast du dein mod key hast du dein mod key nicht auf auf windows
oder alt das das ist die fault oder das nicht die fault dass man das ist das ist die fault
ich habe hier nichts mehr ich habe kein resize und kein kein kein zeug drin
rechte maustaste musst du drücken rechte maustaste jaja rechte sorry das habe ich vergessen
zu erwähnen rechte maustaste musst du drücken hier habe ich schon ganz rechte maustaste
nicht linke warum mit link mit linker maustaste kann man glaube ich die fenster switchen oder
sowas keine ahnung ne oder leute ist das jetzt von windows oder was bin ich hier gerade sehen
ist das von windows oder ist das wait a minute das ist das ist von was bin ich denn hier
gerade sehend irgendjemanden plan was ist das wenn ich linke maustaste wenn ich linke maustaste
drücke ok linke maustaste mit floating window ist klar da kann man es kann man es moveen
aber was ist die linke maustaste denn mit sind es sofort definierte zonen wo man die
irgendwie ach gucke mal mir war ja gar nicht bewusst dass i3 sowas hat das wusste ich
ja gar nicht das ist so art näher so eine art docking was nicht so richtig gut funktioniert
aber ist das neu das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert wusste ich nicht dass es das gibt aber da
sieht man wie oft ich fenster management mache gar nicht weil ich habe browser fullscreen
terminal fullscreen ide fullscreen und edit oder editor fullscreen oder hier editor frontend
ide fullscreen und das war es mir habe ich ja nicht und ich habe das immer im fullscreen
also ich mache ja so gut wie kein window management damit kap ja das gibt es bestimmt schon länger
und ich wusste einfach nicht ich lecke richtig richtig critical information he doesn't know
he lacks critical information kommt das eigentlich her das ist auch so typisch dummer twitch spruch
ja wo kommt das wo kommt da weiß jemand wo das eigentlich herkommt im zweifelsfall excusee
oder sowas hast du einen link zu deinem desktop wallpaper nein der ist tatsächlich hier nicht
drin oder forsen wahrscheinlich forsen wahrscheinlich forsen ja du hast recht wahrscheinlich sowas
kommt höchstwahrscheinlich von forsen ja gehe ich auch von aus den hintergrund habe
ich nicht den hintergrund werde ich auch so erstmal nicht nicht raushauen das ist das
ist ein hintergrund den habe ich auf reddit gefunden und habe ihn ai abscalen lassen
und ich habe gerade meinen thumbnail designer drauf angesetzt einen white people happy begleitet
uns durch den tag background strecke zu erstellen und zwar es wird diesen hintergrund geben
white people happy mit sterne am hintergrund und der mond scheint mit white people happy
und pyjama mit auf und frühstück davor und sowas also es wird für jede so für die meisten
tageszeiten wird es davon ein white people happy background geben und den stelle ich
das stelle ich euch dann zur verfügung wenn es ist dann könnt ihr euren desktop so einstellen
dass der quasi anhand der uhrzeit das hinten in den hintergrund ändert wenn ihr noch gute
ideen habt ihr damit ja weil wir brauchen schon 88 auf der toilette wann geht man dann auf die
toilette nach mittagessen oder so könnte man auch machen wallpaper champ nee das ist ja easy zu
skripten oder irgendwas fertiges zu verwenden so wallpaper switchen arbeitest du für die arbeit
auch in der vm in der hier ja und nein manche sachen mache ich da drüber aber wenn ich remote
arbeiten muss also wo ich mich auch wenn ich mich auch wirklich remote auf systeme einloggen muss dann
habe ich den extra vm nur für die arbeit mit allem drauf was ich da brauche wenn ich wenn
ich irgendwelche sachen entwickle die ich ohne probleme auch lokal ausprobieren kann unabhängig
von irgendwelchen daten auf der arbeit oder so da mache ich das gerne in meiner bestehenden
vm drinnen weil da alles so ist wie ich mich gut dran gewöhnt habe aber ansonsten habe ich für
die arbeit eine eigene vm ubuntu tatsächlich jubantu eine jubantu eine jubantu vm was ist
denn eine heiligen schreibt das schreibt man auch nicht so das hat doch mit dem fisch nichts
zu tun was ist denn eine heiligen schein uhr ach du meinst ein heiligen schein mit mit nur zeiger
so nach dem motto ist es mittag der mittag mittag würde ich den einfach beim bei mittagessen
futtern zeigen so irgendwie döner teller oder sowas döner teller mit fanta irgendwas und was
geht es bei euch um gar nichts heute mir war es einfach nur langweilig und ich habe den bzw ich
wusste nicht so genau was ich jetzt noch anfangen sollte habe ich einfach den stream angemacht es
geht um gar nichts ich habe ein bisschen was über mein linux setup erzählt es geht um kein
spezielles thema heute ich wollte mal gucken ob wir noch ein paar videos haben die uns angucken
können so was haben wir denn hier die wahrheit über informatik mein gehalt mit 25 ok das ist
der dude den wir heute morgen auch schon geguckt haben ok das gucken wir uns jetzt an so ein
video habe ich auch letztens gemacht gucken wir mal was andere was bei anderen so reinkommt
was windows 11 will get redesigned was man sollte windows 11 redesigned werden schon wieder
microsoft hat glaube ich alle leute die sonst nichts zu tun haben stecken die alle in ein
team und da kommt dann rein wir machen windows redesign emulator video war mega schön dass du
herkommt und es extra sagt freut mich wirklich weil das das emulator video also wer das noch
nicht gesehen hat guckt euch nach dem streamer an würde mir auf jeden fall view time mäßig
richtig helfen das video guckt kaum einer das video hat 15.000 oder bis zu ich glaube 8 bis
15.000 views weniger als normal wäre in diesem zeitraum also normalerweise hätte ich jetzt keine
ahnung 15 bis 20.000 oder je nach wenn es gut läuft auch mehr und das hat 10.000
einer nicht viewboten das hat blödsinn also ich hoffe ja ich hoffe ja dass der youtube
algorithmus das erkennt als sinnvolles video was man leute die sich für das thema interessieren
vorschlagen könnte fand es das beste bisher dass ich das freut mich das schön zu hören
ist auch gut geschnitten war das hat sich der teil wirklich mühe gegeben aber es tut
halt view technische ich wir können nur hoffen dass das in youtube algorithmus über zeit über
die zeit ein bisschen so so ab pickt und besser wird was macht meine mini pc kiste aktuell schon
dual boot eingerichtet mini pc kiste die steht tatsächlich hier neben mir auf meinem rechner
obendrauf so dass es den den lüfter den airflow von der wasserkühlung nicht total blockiert steht
auf meinem rechner und ist am monitor angeschlossen ich kann jetzt hin und ich schalte manchmal
hin und her zwischen meinem hauptmonitor und den anderen input und spielen bis hin schlechter
clickbait also ich finde den titel eigentlich ganz gut beste emulator mini pc von switch bis
super nintendo ist doch eigentlich gar kein schlechter titel oder das thumbnail ist auch
ganz gut mit dem switch in der hintergrund ich glaube einfach die leute bei mir interessieren
sich da nicht so für deswegen hoffe ich dass die dass der algorithmus was irgendwie erkennt dass
es vielleicht nicht die richtige zielgruppe ist dass ein paar anderen empfiehlt und das dann auch
durch die youtube suchergebnisse vielleicht auch ein paar views kriegt ist am besten auch der
wird der titel ein bisschen lang ruta neu gestartet sekunde sekunde ich habe ich nicht aber ich gucke
mal ich gucke mal kurz 229 ist immer noch die gewesen ne dann dann immer noch nicht
warum kein sin kleint auch kappa ich weiß aber das ist ja klar so klein wie ältere sin kleins
oder dann mehr leistung
für proxmox und so ja gut da ist die da ist natürlich die eingebaute grafika also da ist
die eingebaute gpu cpu kombi natürlich nicht so wichtig dafür wozu brauchst du eine gescheite
grafikkarte bei einer proxmox kiste was ich glaube ich glaube dass zu erwähnen ist nicht
das problem wo nintendo weil an sich ist das ja ist das ja nichts wo nintendo probleme hat
ist wenn du fake nintendo produkte und sowas zeigst und das dann im titel erwähnt aber
letztendlich ist es random die können ja die können ja machen was sie wollen und du kannst
dich auch nicht wirklich dagegen wehren leider ich meine ich werde an ich werde dann in den
widerspruch einreichen aber wird natürlich nix bringen sollte da was passieren
ja auch nicht alle komisch eigentlich wahrscheinlich wenn
das hauptthema des videos war keine ahnung ja gut in sin klein kostet 30 euro das stimmt
aber damit kannst du auch wenn es hoch kommt 16 bit konsolen emulieren bei allem was danach
kommt macht das ding schon schlapp
ok dann gucken wir uns mal an was er zum thema zu sagen hat die wahrheit über informatik
gehälter der hat das falsch geschrieben ich dachte das heißt informatik core da hat sich
mal von ea einer drüber lustig gemacht leute habe ich euch das erzählt ich habe mal bei
der ea hotline angerufen weil ich damals mein bed company in game item zeug weil das irgendwie
ab bei den an den falschen account gelingt war oder so ich krieg es nicht mal richtig
zusammen da habe ich bei der ea hotline angerufen da wollten die gamertag und name und da habe
ich gesagt informatik core und da meinte der typ zu mir oder war aber wieder einer besonders
lustig er hat ja nicht unrecht aber muss er muss er das so wie muss er das so erzählen
mann
ok gucken wir mal die wahrheit über informatik gehälter auf geht wie viel verdient man eigentlich
als informatiker und software entwickler in deutschland genug sein marktwert zu kennen
und dementsprechend zu verhandeln ist nicht nur ein schöner nehmen warum ist es so leise
absolut notwendig heute morgen war das lauter weil ich weil ich die lautstärke runtergestellt
habe das könnte eine erklärung sein ja ich habe für dead space natürlich die lautstärke
runtergestellt war zu laut in deutschland da spricht man einfach nicht übers geld dem
setzt sich ein verstehe ich verstehe ich auch nicht es hat sich ein bisschen die letzten
jahre ein bisschen gebessert aber dieses permanente geheimnistur rei um das was man verdient bringt
im endeffekt nur dem arbeitgeber was und sonst keinem
und zeig dir unzensiert mein gehaltsverlauf
unzensiert
vom studium bis die ersten jahre im beruf ich zeig dir alles mein gehalt bei welcher firma
und wie viele jahre berufserfahrung
ok bei welcher firma zeige ich euch nicht
wenn ein immer wieder riesige gehälter versprochen
moment zeig mal her zeig mal was wird einem da versprochen
wenn ein immer wieder
140.000 euro im jahr ja ja gut wenn du bei keine ahnung facebook oder so bist da mag
das vielleicht sein oder bei google microsoft oder kann das sein wobei die meisten leute
nach kurzer zeit schon kein bock mehr drauf haben
auf der anderen seite seriously so weit weg von meinem ist es jetzt ja mittlerweile auch
nicht mehr was ich übrigens sehr nice finde
also allein schon aus dem grund hat sich der job wechseln gelohnt
immer noch weg ja immer noch 30k weg von
aber
ist ganz so unrealistisch je nachdem was man macht ist es nicht
riesige gehälter versprochen als 100 euro 100.000 euro für entwicklerunternehmen
sollen eine obergrenze warum sollen was
eine handlungsempfehlung sie sollen eine obergrenze setzen
ok leute geile idee geile idee fife hat wir wollen leute und sagen denen dann ja kommt
zu uns
wir bezahlen euch zwar weniger als die anderen aber kommt zu uns
das wird natürlich voll funktionieren
wenn ich von jahresgehältern rede dann rede ich immer auf fünf tage hochgerechnet
wenn man 100 prozent arbeitet
das ist einfach zum vergleichen viel einfacher
bei mir sind 20 prozent weniger dann
ja ich verstehe dass sie sich das nicht leisten können
dann haben sie aber erstens pech und zweitens können sie ja ihre anforderungen
runterschrauben und selbst versuchen leute sich leute zu fördern ja
die können ja durchaus auch jemand einstellen der nicht 15 jahre erfahrung
hat sondern vielleicht erst angefangen hat einsteiger ist und dem die chance zu
geben sich da zu beweisen und know how aufzubauen gut was dir natürlich immer
passieren kann ist wenn du das als wenn du das als unternehmen machst dass der
sich dann in vier fünf jahren wenn er richtig planen vom acker macht woanders
hin wo er mehr bekommt
ja gut das hast du immer das problem
ok mal gucken also was verdient er denn informatiker was anderes als millionär
zu sein ist eigentlich schon unmöglich
na gut na gut ok ganz so krass ist es nicht
also komm mal selbst wenn du 140 oder 100 selbst wenn du 100k plus im jahr
verdienst das ist ja das ist ja brutto also du bleibst
dir von am ende ja gut
ein bisschen mehr als die hälfte übrig ok und damit millionär zu werden das
dauert trotzdem ein bisschen ja
jeder riesige gehälter versprochen als informatiker was anderes als millionär
zu sein ist eigentlich schon unmöglich einstiegsgehälter mindestens fünf
stunden
ich habe informatik studiert muss die leider enttäuschen ein millionär bin ich
noch nicht aber fangen wir doch erst mal ganz vorne an möglichst früh geld zu
verdienen und besonders billig auf dem arbeitsmarkt zu sein empfehle ich dir
kein klassisches studium an eine universität zu machen auch ich habe dann
ein duales studium angefangen und zwar bei der deutschen bahn
da wäre ich viel zu faul für gewesen ok ich wäre für studium generell viel zu
faul gewesen ok aber duales studium noch viel fauler viel viel viel zu faul
genauer bei der db süßl das ist letztendlich der it dienstleister der bahn
ist also verantwortlich für die für die db für die neue streckenagent ab jetzt
weiß ich jetzt weiß ich bescheid der was
dienstleister der bahn und die vorteile sind eindeutig du sammelst schon mal
berufserfahrung dein studium wird finanziert und du hast ein job sicher als
nachteil kann man da definitiv die mehr belastungen und auch generell weniger
freizeit zu haben ich persönlich habe das aber jetzt auch nicht als so großes
ding wahrgenommen und es ist definitiv machbar als student bei der bahn habt ihr
dann auch noch den vorteil eine persönliche netzkarte zu haben das ist
letztendlich eine bahnkarte 100 für mitarbeiter kommen wir doch jetzt zum
spannenden part dem gehalt im ersten jahr habe ich 1027 euro verdient im
zweiten jahr habe ich dann pro monat im moment das ist das ist azubi gehalt
oder jaja was soll das also was anderes kann es ja schlecht sein pro monat ist
natürlich blöd das kann man ich hoffe die anderen sachen sagt er im jahr weil
ansonsten kann man es überhaupt nicht vergleichen und im dritten 1149 euro pro
monat verdient und als extra kam von der db süstel dann noch ein mietkosten
zuschuss von 300 euro obendrauf also gar nicht so schlecht würde ich sagen also
für eine ausbildung beziehungsweise im studium ist das doch schon mal ganz
nice nach dem studium ging es dann in die
festanstellung ich wurde bei der bahn übernommen
meine tätigkeiten waren hauptsächlich fullstec entwicklung um es ein bisschen
genauer zu machen er hat entwicklung mit einem cross platform framework wie es
für ein konzern üblich ist wurde dann auch nach tarifvertrag vergütet das
heißt als relativ wenig verhandlung spielraum gewesen
da muss ich jetzt mal was zu sagen das ist was was einem arbeitgeber gerne
erzählen so nach dem motto wir haben ja ein
tarifvertrag da gibt es ja keinen verhandlung spielraum
ne ne ne ne tarifvertrag bedeutet nur eine untergrenze nicht zwangsläufig eine
obergrenze also wenn im tarifvertrag drinne steht mit
diesem mit diesen jahren und dieser gehaltgruppe bekommst du 50k im ja dann
heißt das nicht dass sie den ich auch 80k im jahr bezahlen dürfen
die müssen hier mindestens 50k bezahlt so das ist das erste das machen sie
gerne das habe ich auch schon habe ich auch schon persönlich persönlich
gemerkt in den verhandlungen dass man dann argumentiert mit
tarifvertrag aber das ist keine begrenzung für für einen wenn sie
wollen ja dass das geht sondern das zweite ist das einfachste ist man kann
das einfach in boni obendrauf hauen die müssen dich weder in eine andere
tarifgruppe packen noch müssen die irgendwie bei deinen
berufserfahrungsjahren irgendwie faken die können einfach bonus obendrauf
bezahlen dass du mehr bekommst also tarifvertrag wird auch ganz gerne mal so
als ausrede benutzt auf der anderen seite muss man sagen hat natürlich in
tarifvertrag auch seine vorteile wenn es der neue verhandlungen gibt dann
kriegst du die automatisch ob du jetzt bei einer gewerkschaft bist ob du
irgendwelche streitgeschichten oder andere sachen mitmachst habe ich nie
gemacht ich war noch nie mal im leben streiten auf das auf das rumgeschrei
und gefaife hätte ich ja schon mal überhaupt kein bock ich bin auch in
keiner gewerkschaft aber trotzdem habe ich dadurch dass ich bisher in einem
tarifvertrag gewesen bin immer automatisch erhöhen bekommen plus den
bonus obendrauf also da kann ich mich nicht beschweren das war eigentlich
ganz gute kombi
aber dafür sind gehaltssprünge in den nächsten jahren fast garantiert
2020 du kriegst du kriegst du kriegst automatisch immer mal wieder was ich
glaube gab gibt jetzt gibt jetzt erst wieder oder gab jetzt irgendwie glaube
8 prozent oder sowas beim versicherungsgewerbe tarifvertrag dass
azubis in der tarifgruppe 3 und studenten in der tarifgruppe 4 bei der
übernahme eingestiegen sind mit diesen infos könnte ja 8 prozent bei 10 prozent
inflation ja so ist es halt das gehalt nachschauen denn die tarifverträge
sind auch öffentlich einsehbar ich habe damals bei 42
urlaub also ich kann euch sagen ich kann euch zeigen wie mein aktueller
tarifvertrag aussieht aber wie gesagt ist ja bald ist ja bald eh nicht mehr
relevant weil man neuen job habe ich keinen tarifvertrag
arg wäre es oder so
wie heißen die akv fers eine güde alter so tarifverträge für die private
versicherungswirtschaft
frag mich nicht warum ich bei einer bank bin aber unter den tarifvertrag falle ich
habe keine ahnung wahrscheinlich können die sich aussuchen was unterschreiben
ich habe keinen plan kein blasen schimmer ihr gehalt tarifvertrag stand
vierter december 2022 gültig hier da guck du mal ich bin ich
bin glaube ich weiß es gar nicht ich glaube ich glaube ich bin in der gruppe
aktuell
bin mir nicht ganz sicher also drunter bin ich auf kein ne ich glaube ich bin in
der gruppe aber ich bin ich glaube ich bin gehalt gruppe 6 und habe 14 jahre
erfahrung das heißt laut tarifvertrag muss ich
mindestens das hier bekommen das heißt wenn man nur nach tarifvertrag geht
hallo warum kann man das nicht copy pasten
habt ihr
warum deaktiviert man copy in dem pdf warum macht man so einen schwachsinn
ok dann schreibe ich hab 4539 4539 mal 14 so null
das ist ja eine ganze ecke unter dem was es wirklich ist
bin ich vielleicht doch gruppe ich habe keine ahnung welche gruppe ich bin ok
das kommt realistischer hin ne ne sind 14 14 sind bei mir
genau gut bei mir kommt ja noch bei mir gesagt bei mir kommt ja noch bonus um
drauf das ist es ja dann auch immer in da auch im endeffekt aber ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass es so eine große große abweichung ist von dem was im
tarifvertrag steht verse mit bonus verse ist das was mindestens bezahlt
werden muss also sprich guck mal 4539 mal 14
das sind quasi über ja sagen wir mal 10.000 euro unterschied
über 10.000 euro unterschied zum tarifvertrag also mal also ihr seht die
können da durchaus mit bonus was machen das ist das mindeste was sie bezahlen
müssen
ok zeig mal sind wir stehen geblieben sind mit diesen infos könntet ihr
letztendlich auch schon dann bist du ja laut sparkasse kein geringverdiener ich
glaube das bin ich tatsächlich nicht ne dementsprechend muss ich auch fucking
viel steuern bezahlen was mir zwar auf der einen seite
ist es ja ok müssen müssen alle so ihren anteil ihren anteil bringen aber
mir geht schon ein bisschen auf den sack wenn ich sehe dass fast nichts was
mich großartig interessiert und wichtig ist von meinen steuergeldern gemacht
werden aber das ist anderes thema und denn die tarifverträge sind auch online
öffentlich einsehbar ich habe damals mit 42 urlaubstagen 43.000 euro pro
jahr verdient ein kleiner disclaimer es kommt nicht immer auf die urlaubsbasis
wie viel jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich aufgepasst
ok das war sein erster job ok das war sein erster job bei der bahn 42
urlaubstage das ist doch ganz schön viel oder
sind sind normal sind normal nicht irgendwie 30 oder so oder 30 oder
ja also 12 urlaubstage mehr als gesetzlich oder so wie irgendwie oder 32
kann ist das ist doch ganz gut ja
also 42 finde ich finde ich da finde ich da ganz gut
gut dafür gibt es auch ein bisschen weniger geld aber ich mein 14 tage mehr
urlaub ist doch auch nicht verkehrt was ich habe ich habe 30 stunden nicht 35
stunden
ach so ach so meinst du das du meinst wie das hier wie das hier gerechnet ist
ok
ja keiner weiter 40.000 euro verdient ein kleiner disclaimer es kommt nicht immer
auf die urlaubstage und das gehalt an es gibt auch noch viele weitere
incentives vom arbeitgeber die gar nicht so schlecht sein können
zum beispiel der klassische obskorb irgendwelche essen gutscheine das halte
ich jetzt aber mal für ein gerücht chat das halte ich jetzt aber mal für ein
gerücht ja
dieser fisch mir kommt ein name übelst bekannt vor
moment
kennen wir uns nähe oder
also mir kommt mich irgendwo im hinterkopf sagt mir der name was
irgendwas sagt mir der name können auch können auch die bett sein aber ja aber
das wäre ganz schön viel oder armutsgrenze das gibt doch genug gibt
doch genug die 3600 euro netto ist ganz schön viel für viele leute
ja alles unter 10.000 im monat ist eh nix
ach so für die ganze familie ok dann ist es natürlich was anderes ja dass das ist ok das
ist was anderes ja dann das lasse ich mir gefallen ja ok und letztendlich ist
viel wichtiger wie das arbeitsklima ist und das ist auf jeden fall nicht
unwichtig also ich hätte keinen bock mich permanent jeden tag abzufacken
mit den leuten versteht aber darauf werde ich in diesem video weniger
eingehen der job bei der bahn sollte aber auch nicht allzu lange halten
ok während der korona zeit ging es dann auch wieder in den schönsten teil von
deutschland nämlich in meine heimat in norddeutschland und nach knapp sieben
monaten in der auch in frankfurt er war da bei der bahn direkt in frankfurt ich
habe gedacht die haben noch andere standorte in deutschland
frankfurt normalerweise würde ich jetzt sagen frankfurt beste aber das stimmt
nicht frankfurt ist nicht beste beziehungsweise knapp vier jahren im
konzern was man will sie spritzen in den armen heute das start-up leben kennen
lernen und so das start-up lebe plattformen match dayo ein job bei
match dayo gefunden habe weniger prozesse weniger politik und mehr
selbstbestimmtheit haben den wechsel motiviert hier habe ich dann hauptsache
kann ich mir vorstellen dass das für viele die vorher bei so einem großen
laden gewesen sind ich meine ich ich war ja auch mehr oder weniger immer bei einem
großen laden ich war am anfang bei einem provider der war jetzt nicht so krass
groß wie das wo ich jetzt bin aber auch schon ein bisschen größer und aber
dort für die wo wir gearbeitet haben das war halt alles riesen riesen
unternehmen also ich kenne so diese kleine
wie paar mann klitschen kenne ich gar nicht kann ich überhaupt nichts zu sagen
also ich könnte mir vorstellen dass das auch durchaus seinen reiz hat dort zu
arbeiten
nicht oder angelsche für den zapp
tatsächlich frontendaufgaben übernommen durfte mich aber auch in den
verschiedensten anderen bereichen wie marketing design oder was sonst so an
viel ausprobieren in den ersten sechs monaten habe ich 45.000 euro verdient
nach der probezeit 50.000 euro und als ich den job dann verlassen
habe 46.000 euro 400 warum wurde weniger also sprich warum es weniger wurde das
weiß ich weil er nur noch weil er nur noch 80 prozent arbeitet das hat er in
einem anderen video heute morgen erzählt
gut in der zwischenzeit habe ich eine vier tage beziehungsweise 32 stunden
woche angefangen für die vereinfachtung werde ich euch das aber alles mal auf
eine ganz normale fünf tage woche hochrechnen damit kommen wir auch zum
september 20 ok und jetzt gibt's wo ich meine hälfte pass auf beim it dienst
leister it heratec angefangen habe mit ich glaube 80 mit arbeitern
ich dachte 80.000 am standort hamburg ist es ein super kompromiss zwischen
start-up und konzern und bietet die chance extrem viel zu lernen die
möglichkeit von mehr weiterbildung das musste er jetzt wahrscheinlich einbauen
weil sein chef das video guckt von meinen kollegen best practices zu lernen
haben mich hierher verschlagen auch das hat er bestimmt noch 1 zu 1 so im
vorstellungsgespräch gesagt die chance von meinen kollegen best practices zu
lernen haben mich hierher verschlagen klingt super überzeugend alles klar
stundenwoche kann ich hier wirklich fortführen
ok nice darf ich darf ich übrigens auch darf ich übrigens auch beim neuen
oh ein defops engineer engineer umfeld tätig dass ich hier um projekttätigkeit
handelt kann sich das aber immer wieder ändern was denkst du habe ich deine
erwartung bis jetzt getroffen oder willst du über einzelne stationen noch
mehr ich will wissen was er da jetzt schreibt es mir gern in die kommentare
rechnen wir also jetzt alles zusammen und noch die für ok lass mal überlegen
also da ist gewechselt von am ende 56 ja dann wird er wahrscheinlich jetzt denke
ich mal irgendwie 70 80 oder so bekommen 23 garantierte tantime bekomme ich eine
gesamtvergütung von 49 200 alle 61 ok bisschen bisschen mehr nicht schon
gedacht aber ok man in hamburg ist vielleicht weiß ich ob das leben
günstiger ist also bekommt er ungefähr 61 auf fünf tage hochgerechnet um ein
ähnliches oder besseres gehalt zu erzielen hilft es ein profi im
programmieren zu sein damit du das möglichst schnell oder man muss in der
region sein und in der branche und natürlich auch ein bisschen ahnung
haben die mehr bezahlen ok das stimmt ich glaube mit 25 habe ich auch noch
weniger verdient ja mit 25 habe ich auf jeden fall weniger verdient
ja das stimmt
erreichen kannst habe ich hier ein paar punkte für dich zusammengefasst auch an
die inflation angepasst
wahrscheinlich sogar inflation angepasst wie waren deine sprünge ok also
bisschen gedudel an
auf einmal zu laut war mir jetzt zu laut aber ich den sound lauter gemacht
haben ok also wie war meine sprünge also ausbildung keine ahnung kann ich euch
beim besten will nicht mehr sagen aber aber nicht so viel wie er auch
inflationsbereit nicht wahrscheinlich so viel wäre so also ausbildung kein plan
beim provider habe ich angefangen glaube ich mit 33.500 ich sage das immer
in fünf tage woche ja beim provider angefangen habe ich glaube ich mit
33.500 damals das ging dann hoch auf 36.000 relativ schnell dann bin ich
irgendwann gewechselt habe ich den arbeitgeber gewechselt dort ich weiß
gar nicht mehr ehrlich gesagt was dort einstiegsgehalt war aber ich sage jetzt
einfach 45k oder sowas keine ahnung und das ging dann kontinuierlich hoch auf
50 irgendwann auch mal neue tarifgruppe ein bisschen bonus auf 55 60 68 und 70
und jetzt ein bisschen über 70 ein bisschen ein bisschen über 70 ist gut
ich überlege gerade weil es gab ja es gab ja letztes jahr nicht wirklich bonus
ja irgendwas um 75k da über den daumen gepeilt so ist es irgendwie so was in dem
dreh hochgerechnet auf fünf tage woche 40 stunden korrekt ja ja so und bei meinem
neuen job sind es dann halt einfach mal 105k ist einfach mal krass viel mehr
aber hey ok letzt letztes jahr war es wahrscheinlich bei dem alten job auch
eher 80k weil zwar kein kein riesen bonus dazugekommen ist aber
inflationsausgleich und gedönst und sowas ja
aber trotzdem also der neue job ist schon deutlich besser bezahlt als mein
aktueller in welchem jahr hast du 33.500 verdient ich denke mal 2009 2010 rum
ja kommt hin
also das eigentliches galt war jetzt nicht so der wahnsinn auch damals schon nicht
ja schweiz schweiz zählen ich ja es schwankt also wer es genau wissen will
ich habe dazu ich habe dazu ja ein video gemacht ich kann es euch aber da so viel
verdiene ich jetzt habe ich video zu gemacht ich kann es euch natürlich nicht 100 prozentig
sagen weil ich habe es ja noch nicht unterm strich jetzt gesehen nach einem
jahr aber es ist halt eine spanne von 95k bis 115k ist da möglich je nachdem wie
viel bonus es gibt wie gut das jahr lief wie erfolgreich meine eigenen sachen
gelaufen sind wie viele wartungsarbeiten vielleicht zuschläge es gibt vielleicht
mal bereitschaft gemacht oder sowas also zwischen also das mindeste ist glaube ich
irgendwas um 95k und und wenn es gut gelaufen ist und bisschen bereitschaft
sowas dabei gekommen ist dann dann kann es bis zu irgendwie 115k sein mit einer
muss aber wirklich alles richtig gut laufen also ist es eine große große
schwankungen irgendwie drin aber das finde ich gar nicht schlecht ich meine
letztendlich ist es base mäßig schon wenn es mindeste ist schon echt nicht
schlecht und wenn man sich ein bisschen anstrengt dann gibt es auch hat er dann
lohnt sich das wenigsten sich anzustrengen ist auch mal was was natürlich
krass ist wenn man sich überlegt dass es quasi eine steigerung ist von 300 prozent
so also es ist dreifache so quasi also ich verdiene jetzt dann ungefähr recht
genau das dreifache von meinem einstiegsgehalt nach 15 jahren
ich weiß nicht ob das normal ist wie sich das irgendwie die entwicklung ist
aber ich denke mal dass ich die nächsten die nächsten 15 jahre nicht mehr 300
prozent mehr verdienen werde das wäre vielleicht bisschen weird champ anzunehmen
die kombination ist frankfurt finanz branche das ist das wo einfach viel
kohle drin ist und ich meine ich will mich jetzt nicht über gebühren selbst
loben das gehört sicher nicht aber so ein bisschen ahnung von dem bereich was
ich mache habe ich ja auch jetzt nach 15 jahren und und beim beim
vorstellungsgespräch wurde mir übrigens erzählt dass ich mit 38 für sie
besonders interessant bin weil irgendwie ihr altersschnitt zu hoch ist und mit 38
bin ich quasi ein bestager und das wäre eh das allerbeste okay den begriff habe
ich vorher noch nie gehört aber jetzt weiß ich dass ich ein bestager bin
also quasi weder suma noch boomer ich dachte du bist jünger ich bin 38 ein
bestager
also also quasi bin ich im giga chat alter du bist 28 bin zehn jahre älter
aber genug genug geld money zeug jetzt kann man so irgendwas rein fahren da
sehe ich mich der typ heute morgen im video da sehe ich mich der hat sich
überall gesehen der hat sich auch in der schisha bar gesehen abends
noch ein richtiges kokona video wie ist es eine AC 130 abzufeuern
lull was erst mal den fetten 120 millimeter mörser da rausholen
ok wo darf er wo darf er ballern den ich 120 105 ok 105
sieht ja fast aus wie call of duty briefing screen hier
firing gun ok hier darf er
krasse vergrößerung oder alter über krasse vergrößerung guck mal
ja ich bin ich bin bescheuert man ich sollte vielleicht die lautstärke mal
ändern das braucht man halt um die freiheit zu verteidigen verstehe ich
ach nee das ist der große oder was ne welcher welcher war das jetzt
also aus kott weiß ich das ding hat drei drei verschiedene schussmodi einmal so
ne so ne so ne so ne 30 millimeter maschinengewehr oder sowas so eine richtig fette 120 millimeter
mörser kann oder 105 und und irgendwas dazwischen
ok so that was pretty cool but i think it's time that we move to the gun i have been waiting
patiently for yep gun to the 105 millimeter cannon for this things were going to work a
little bit differently instead of just was zum teufel sind bofors ich kenn bofors
pulling the trigger we were going to simulate a real life fire mission this is how things
would work in a real life combat situation with friendly forces on the ground calling
in an air strike hat man in kott auch reise gezogen so ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
that first piece of comms is from the simulated controller on the ground who is calling in
the initial request for an air strike send it my position op jockey no mark target location
is 140 530 meters group of three tanks in the open no mark over i then responded send
it which prompts the controller to transmit the coordinates in target in this case a group
of three enemy tanks specter 61 copies looking tally target die amis direkt in den meter
davos darauf ankommt dass auch getroffen wird one enemy tank now this final piece of comms
you'll hear is my favorite part because it includes a checklist rundown from the entire
crew as the whizzo or weapon systems officer i'll relay the gun type ammunition and distance
to target which then allows the sizzle or combat system wobei in der raumfahrt nicht
unbedingt bei der bei der internationalen raumstation gab es ja mal das problem dass
die einen in inches gerechnet haben und die anderen in centimeter to confirm it then goes
to the pilot who has a consent switch up in the flight deck before going back down to
the gunners who load the ammunition and confirm that gun two is ready to fire to whizzo got
to trainable prox target 140 530 meters whizzo ready to confirm are two two are sind jetzt
eigentlich gerade im simulator oder fliegen die wirklich
das ist hier maus kokona video ever
so if you've stuck around this long you'll know that there's still one thing i have left
to do experience loading the 105 millimeter cannon myself as i pulled on my gloves and
made my way to the rear of the aircraft i realized this was not going to be the easiest thing
i'd ever done handling 50 pound rounds at almost 10 000 feet in the air while experiencing
some pretty bad turbulence let's hope i brought my a gang all right sam we're gonna get you
on the 105 shooting some tp rounds you get with that ich meine letztendlich ist das einfach
schlicht und ergreifend 14 minuten werbung für die was ist das air force zu was auch immer
das ist 14 minuten werbung für das kokona militär im endeffekt
den it sounded especially remembering how to arm it once it was in the gun i gave it
my best shot all right 30 selected so you're gonna close your breach it's a f1 and then
arm it your gun ready a little rusty and definitely lacking the speed that an actual ac 130 gunner
has but hey not bad for my first time i gave it a few more goes but then decided it was
stimmt mehr bock dafür in die army zu gehen hatte ich auch nicht nachdem ich das geguckt
aber mehr fun to let the experts have added as we finished up our final few rounds before
landing der hatte bestimmt die auflage für das video dass die army cool dargestellt werden
muss ok zum abschluss brauchen wir jetzt das muss zum abschluss jetzt zu diese
im video zum abschluss sein almost heaven older twitch chat all these emotes wonderin
how to spell that now we're older everyone's but i remember ich gehe nicht auf leute
nein nein nein ich gehe doch nicht auf zum abfluss von dem video jetzt noch mal ein
richtigen kokona song kappa poc jen typing dance game swift rage pj salt and fail fish
eats spamming all the time t.o.s was nowhere so everyone's feeling fine twitchy mode long
go made you feel you're not alone four people talk to him by them
Directory
Wann geht's her?
Du bist nicht allein, Pong ist Pong-Cham, Cap ist Cap-Bug, BibleThump, TwitchyMonts, PepeHands, TwitchyMonts, BibleThump, TwitchyMonts.
Das muss die jetzt sein, aber hinten drauf, ey.
Easy Clap.
Da gab es noch keinen Prime-Sub, ja, das stimmt.
Wobei man sagen muss, Prime-Sub an sich ist eigentlich was ziemlich Gutes, weil ich glaube, dass vor Prime-Sub deutlich und zwar wirklich deutlich weniger Streamer davon leben konnten.
Die vielleicht wollten und auch gerne täglichen Streaming-Crime machen wollten und so, aber einfach schlicht und ergreifend nicht von leben konnten.
Nur von quasi Paid-Sub extra registriert und subscribt und alles.
Also ich glaube, dank Twitch Prime können viel mehr Streamer jetzt davon leben.
Ja gut, und es gab noch keine, wir sitzen am Pool und halten unsere Bubas in die Kamera-Streams, die gab es noch nicht.
Schaut ihr nach in den Super Bowl, nein, mich interessiert kaum Sport und dazu zählt auch Football.
Also zu den Sachen, die mich auch nicht interessieren, zählt Football auch dabei.
Super Bowl, das ist dann aber mal so richtig Kokona-Style wieder.
Dieses Jahr ist Boring, warum ist es dieses Jahr Boring?
Ich habe überhaupt keinen Plan davon.
Nick, danke für den Sub.
Ja, das war ein richtiger Pains Champions im Chat eben.
Brianna, okay, das juckt mich auch mal überhaupt nicht.
Nein, wir haben nur die Hälfte der Happy Server gemacht, das kommt noch. Also heute nicht, aber wir machen die noch.
Wollen wir uns noch angucken?
Intel vs. AMD, wer es besser macht? Okay, nein, da kommt wahrscheinlich nichts Scheides bei rum, das ist bestimmt doch richtig das Video wieder.
Welche Firewall-Lösung präferierst du? Ich habe vom Netzwerkbereich nicht so wirklich Ahnung.
Wisst ihr was die letzte Firewall war, an der ich regelmäßig administriert habe?
Das kennen wahrscheinlich kaum noch einer. Kennt noch jemand Checkpoint Firewall 1?
Okay, Checkpoint Firewall. Firewall 1 hieß das glaube ich, ja.
Ja, so sah das Gui aus, ich erinnere mich noch. Es kann durchaus sein, dass es sogar Windows Only war.
Wie gesagt, ich bin netzwerktechnisch nicht der Super-Checker was neue Sachen angeht.
Also so Netzwerkequipment, ich könnte mich da durchaus einlesen und würde das wahrscheinlich auch dann administrieren können, aber ich habe da nicht wirklich Plan von. Ich kann dir sagen, was ich daheim habe.
Daheim habe ich einen Mikrotik-Router, der so ein bisschen basic Firewall Sachen macht und das reicht. Gab es nicht mal ein Microsoft Firewalls, es gab mal, wie hieß das von Microsoft?
Microsoft ESA Server hieß das, genau ich erinnere mich wieder. ESA Server hieß das mal von Microsoft dieses Ding.
Ja, das habe ich auch mal irgendwann gesehen.
Internet Security und Acceleration Server, als hätte der IES jemals was Accelerated. Ja, so sah das Ding damals aus.
Habe ich aber auch nie was großartig mit zu tun gehabt.
Also, ja, das stimmt voll. Zurück Accelerated haben die, die haben quasi gebremst. Reverse Acceleration, die haben quasi abgebremst.
Es ist ähnlich wie Negative Latency, genau.
Nee, aber wie gesagt, also von irgendwie Netzwerk, Netzwerkequipment, da mache ich viel zu wenig mit, als dass ich da großartig, großartig Ahnung habe, was das anbelangt.
Wir haben einen Dienstleister, der kümmert sich um das meiste Netzwerk technisch, also ich muss da auch gar nichts machen.
Also, ja, das stimmt voll.
Ja, ja, gut, die kenne ich vom Namen her. Was ist das für eine Musik? Das ist Crip of the Necrodancer, der Soundtrack.
Cooles Game, nie super viel gespielt, aber der Soundtrack ist mega Pogu.
Und nein, es ist nicht Darude Sunstorm, auch wenn das die Standard Antwort ist auf Twitch für alles. Gibt es da nicht sogar ein eigenes, ja, gibt ein eigenes E-Mode für.
Ja, gut, ich überlege gerade, gucken wir, gucken wir uns doch irgendwas an oder gehe ich, gehe ich jetzt schon off?
Ich weiß nicht so wirklich, also großartig langes habe ich keinen Bock, spätestens 22 Uhr gehe ich eh pen.
Du hast recht, wir müssten uns noch ein paar Unix Porn Bilder angucken aus dem Discord. Okay, das machen wir jetzt, ja, wir gucken uns.
Nee, Windos juckt mich nicht. Wir gucken uns, beim Captain Poggers sind wir stehen geblieben.
Unix Porn aus dem Discord gucken wir uns an. Wo ist mein Discord? Da und dort gibt es ein Unix Porn Channel.
Okay, also wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Wir Serious Max hatten wir, Stinkface hatten wir, Stripes hatten wir, den Adrian hatten wir, Tbilius hatten wir, Captain Poggers.
Okay, auf gehts, schauen wir uns das ganze mal an. Copy Link, ich habe wieder Mist, ich habe wieder Mist kopiert, Open im Browser, Open im Browser, so.
Ja, das ist ja, also viel klassischer Debian kannst du ja nicht mehr haben. Pass auf, am Ende ist es Chebat, wisst ihr was?
Wahrscheinlich ist das gar kein Debian, sondern Archlinux und hat einfach das Debian Logo im Hintergrund. Und dann hat er uns alle einmal richtig heftig.
You got Chebated, you got, you got Chebated.
Hat uns einmal alle richtig Chebated. Okay, ne, es ist tatsächlich ein Debian. Es ist Debian Bookworm. Okay, ist Bookworm das neue? Welcher, Moment, Bookworm Toy Story, welcher ist das?
Welcher ist das von Toy Story? An den kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr erinnern. Ach, der war auch nur aus Toy Story 3. Toy Story 3 habe ich einmal geguckt und ich war aber okay.
Welches Toy Story war das mit den Aliens und der Klaue in diesem Automat drinne? Die Klaue? Ich glaube das war zwei oder war das sogar der erste schon?
Sind die Debian Distros nach Toy Story benannt? Ja, alle, alle. Debian Versions, alle. Guck, das sind alles, ich glaube Woody ist den einzigen, den jeder kennt.
Jesse kennen die meisten wahrscheinlich auch noch. Bullseye, ist das nicht der Dinosaurier? Ach ne, das ist Buster, Moment, wer ist das? Wie heißt der Dinosaurier?
Dinosaurier? Rex? Okay, ne. Dann hatte der noch nie einen. Stretch ist der Hund, dieser Dackel zum Jaja. Guck mal, Stretch ist jetzt old, old stable.
Und das ist quasi old, Jesse ist old, old, old stable. Buster, Toy Story, wer ist Buster? Buster ist doch, okay. Jaja, also die Debian Dinger sind alle nach Toy Story Charakters benannt.
So, sehr klassischer i3, sehr Standard i3, muss ich sagen. Die i3 Leiste im Standard gefällt mir nicht. Sowohl das schwarze Hintergrund als auch die Farbe ist nicht meins.
Dafür hat er ein hübsches Terminal, wobei man auch am Terminal noch ein bisschen was verbessern könnte, nämlich zum Beispiel, dass das Terminal selbst zum Dark Theme passt, also sprich er müsste irgendeinen GTK Theme nehmen, was das Terminal eben dunkel macht.
Dann wäre das wahrscheinlich hübscher. Captain Poggers.
Der Rest ist klassisch i3, gar nicht so viel getunt dran. Kann man auf jeden Fall mitarbeiten, Wishlist Studios Default. Was ich ganz gut finde, dass er glaube ich die gleiche Farbe im Terminal hat wie in Wishlist Studios.
Ach guck mal, er verwendet Konsole. Okay, ich kenne kaum einen der Konsole verwendet, außer vielleicht Leute, die auch KDE verwenden in Kombination.
Fisch, auch einer der wenigen Leute, der Fisch als Shell verwendet, kenne ich auch nicht so viele. Okay, es ist eine Installation auf echter Hardware, einen 1044p Bildschirm und der Rechner ist auch recht nice.
Wenn auch schon ein paar Jahre älter, aber noch nicht super alt. Guck mal, er hat ein Jawsor Plugin. Okay, next.
Wenn er mal als nächstes, wer kommt als nächstes im Discord? Vorti kommt als nächstes. Okay, Vorti hat nur einen Screenshot von seinem Desktop gepostet, dafür einen Breiten mit buntem Auto.
Er hat seine WLAN SSID schon mal gehydet, sonst kommen nämlich die Hacker-Mans aus dem Chat und Brute Forsten sein WPA Kennwort.
Nee, da stand nicht Intel Prozessor, da stand Ryzen.
Da, Ryzen.
Zumindest ein bisschen Customize die Leiste. Ich bin halt echt kein Fan der normalen Leiste mit diesem Grün und dem Rot, das gefällt mir persönlich nicht. Deswegen habe ich es halt bei mir so aktuell mit der Leiste.
Jo, und ansonsten, was hat er denn noch? Das ist ein klassischer i3, ohne Icons, ohne sonst was auch unten mit der Leiste.
Terminal ist optisch ganz nice. Er hat drinnen KDE, nee das sieht nicht aus wie KDE. Ihr i3, auch Konsole und Hack, sehr gute Schriftart. Moment, was hat der Captain Poggers als Schriftart?
Steht da gar nicht drinnen. Kein Terminal-Font, da braucht es neuere Neo-Fetch Varianten. Was ist eigentlich das angesagtere Leute? Screen-Fetch oder Neo-Fetch? Was verwenden die coolen Leute?
Wieso du jetzt erst hier bist, das kann ich dir auch nicht sagen. Sag mal schön, dass du hier bist.
Neo-Fetch ist der neueste Shit. Petten Monitor hat er am Start. Alter, die haben aber viele Packages installiert. Lass mal kurz gucken. Hab ich Neo-Fetch drauf? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Net-Fetch, man. Neo-Fetch. Kann ich mal schreiben. Neo-Fetch.
Packages, 6,890, ja. Sieht schon sinnvoller aus.
Lipkaka. Ok, nice. Aber Arch-By-The-Way ist es. Was sonst? 7 Flatpacks, 2037 Packages, ZSH am Start und ein Arch-Linux mit i3.
Ok, wen haben wir als nächstes? Oh, einen Gnome-Desktop-Benutzer. Die gibt es anscheinend auch noch. Und zwar den Shryker95, den habe ich gerade schon im Chat gesehen.
Der scheiß Gnome, genau. Ok, das ist schon mal eine Auflösung, damit komme ich klar. Ordentliche Auflösung, da erkennt man wenigstens was.
Welcher Font ist das? Ist das Inkonsolata? Was ist das für ein Font? Shryker, du bist ja da. Ist das Inkonsolata? Was ist das für ein Font? Oder ist das Hack? Aber für Hack ist das ein bisschen langgezogen.
Ok, ok, ok. Aber das Frontrendering ist ganz hübsch. Gut, ich meine, dass es mittlerweile überall ansehnlich ist. So könnte ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen, auch Gnome zu verwenden. Aber Gnome nervt mich trotzdem.
Deswegen bleibe ich bei E3. Sieht aber schick aus. Flat Remix Blue. Das Theme gucke ich mir tatsächlich mal an. Flat Remix. Welches davon?
Flat Remix Git? Flat Remix Gnome? Welches brauche ich davon? Oder GTK? Und warum gibt es das 500 Mal?
Flat Remix GTK, ok. Mal gucken, wie das ausschaut.
Alter, was jetzt? Wer war das Chat?
Ok, Alex Appearance. Oh, so viel. Und welches davon? Dark, Blue, Dark. Nee, GTK, Blue, Dark. Blue, Darkest, nee.
Ich muss sagen, ist eigentlich ganz hübsch. Welches hast du da? Blue, Dark. Icon? Was hast du für ein Icon Theme am Start? Ich finde das ganz hübsch.
Ja, das ist nice. Wobei ich sagen muss, ich glaube, ich bleibe bei meinem. Ja, kann man sich jetzt darüber streiten.
Flat Remix Blue, Dark. Ach, Flat Remix, das ist ein eigenes Icon Pack, gibt es auch noch. Ok, ich lasse das hier mal. Flat Remix Icon.
Ok, welches davon? Ach, hier eins. Das Rit Repo.
Auf, auf. Jetzt mach mal hin, Mensch, Pac-Man, installier mal. Wobei ist es ja gar nicht Pac-Man.
Das dauert jetzt. Warum? Was machen die? Ha, Toppo. Jetzt, das klingt wie aus irgendeinem Anime.
Ah, der erstellt irgendwelche. User bin faked, jetzt geht es schon los. Ah, Toppo. Bin faked. Also wenn meine Festplatte voll ist, dann weiß ich, woher es kommt.
Wenn wir schon beim Thema sind, wie spricht denn der Hexer von heute Java und Javascript aus? Java und Javascript. Ich zumindest.
Es gibt coole Leute, die sagen Java oder Javascript oder sowas. Oder manche sagen auch JS oder sowas. Ich bin für Javascript.
Was? JS-Script? Nee, das sagt keiner so.
Die Amis sagen auch ganz gerne Javascript, so mit dem Langgezogener. Javascript.
Alter, was macht der mit den Icons gerade? Macht der meine Festplatte voll oder? Was ist happening hier? Javascript ist happening.
Nee, nicht wirklich. Man kann ja vieles auf Javascript schieben, aber dass ein Icon meine Festplatte voll macht, eher nicht.
Der hat Icons für alles, werde ich gleich sehen. Ah, jetzt hat er es. Jetzt hat er es. Ich freue mich schon auf Updates.
Alles klar. Okay, Alex Appearance. Alter, was macht der hier ohne? Ja, bleiben.
Flat Remix Dark. Flat Remix Blut. Oh, das ist schick. Das lassen wir mal. Gucken wir mal. Tuna.
Leute, ich muss sagen, die Leiste hier oben und die GUI-Programme passen jetzt viel besser zusammen.
Das ist, ich glaube, das ist eine gute, das ist eine gute Icon und Theme Wahl. Ich restarte mal kurz, dass ich alles andere auch.
Ich muss nicht wirklich restarten, das reicht, wenn ich den, wenn ich X neu starte. Gucken, wie die Icons hier oben dargestellt werden.
Okay, nice. Auch gut, gut, gut, gut. Ja, okay, das ist so ein Dover, das ist so ein Dover Netzwerkstecker, wo man immer nicht genau erkennt, was es sein soll, aber okay.
Ja. Aber Moment, ich muss, ich muss mein, mein Rofi-Theme noch umstellen, dass das ordentlich. Waren wir jetzt mal schnell? Wim-Config-Rofi-Rofi-Config-Icon-Theme ist, oh, wie muss ich das jetzt nennen?
Ähm, soll ich das so hinschreiben? Flat Remix Blue Dark. Ja, hat funktioniert. Sehr schick, nice.
Nice. Das gefällt mir, das hat echt was. Ja. Schöne, schönes, schönes Theme und schöne, schöne Icons.
Ja, hast recht. Ja, ich könnte den hier machen zum Neustart. Ich hab das gar nicht mehr gemapped, weil ich immer den, immer einfach in X-Rover abschieße und neu starte.
Schön, schönes Icon-Theme und auch so, und auch so ganz, ganz nice. Jetzt passt natürlich, jetzt passt natürlich mein, mein Rofi nicht mal so ganz dazu, aber ich werde, ich werde damit leben können.
Aber, aber nice, nice. Das behalte ich mal bei. Guck ich mir mal ein bisschen an. Macht doch eine andere Farbe.
Stimmt, mal gucken, was sonst noch dabei ist. Ob es da irgendwas gibt, was da näher, was da näher dran kommt.
Brown Dark? Nee, Moment, da ändert sich ja nichts. Das ist ja nicht der Hintergrund, der sich ändert, sondern, oh, Moment.
Da ändert sich nicht der Hintergrund, da ist immer nur die Farben davor. Das kann ich nicht anpassen.
Magenta Dark? Oh ja, unbedingt. Ey, Blue Dark ist okay. Passt schon, passt schon.
Das ist schon OK. Ich mache das mal auf, da ich nächstes Mal dran denke, dass ich neue Icons installiert habe.
So, nächster. Find ich schick, hat mich, hat mich inspired. Dein Desktop. So, wen haben wir denn als nächstes?
Oh, das ist ja. Wie jetzt einfach das neue, das andere Video angefangen hat.
Oh, komm mal, als nächstes haben wir einen User. Wer macht denn sowas?
Stripe Server. Gut, das ist 0815 Ubuntu Desktop, da ist überhaupt nichts dran angepasst.
Okay, vielleicht ein bisschen, aber zum Glück auch fetter, fetter, fetter Cursor am Start.
Jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt der Tommy. Der ist vielleicht gerade im Stream. Heute Morgen war er da. Ich weiß nicht, ob er jetzt da ist.
Tommy Desktop. Oh, auch schick. Ist das Windows? Oder sieht das einfach nur aus wie Windows?
Es ist, es ist glaube ich einfach nur ein Windows Skin, oder? Es ist gar kein Windows. Das ist ein Gnome mit Windows Skin oder irgendwie so.
Ubuntu. Fuck, ein Windows 10. Das ist, das ist, das ist WSL. Wer macht denn sowas?
Na gut, ich meine manchmal kommt man nicht dran vorbei, aber ich muss ehrlich gesagt zugeben, das sieht doch ganz brauchbar aus.
Stimmt, warum steht da Windows 10 und das sieht aus wie Windows 11? Vielleicht ist das extremes G-Bait. Vielleicht ist das, warum ist das?
Das ist bestimmt, Moment, Moment, Moment. Das ist bestimmt kein Windows. Der verarscht uns wahrscheinlich einfach nur.
Der hat bestimmt ein KDE oder ein Gnome mit Windows Skin und das Neo Fetch hat er so eingestellt, dass es so tut, als wäre es ein Windows.
Ansonsten ist es für mich jetzt so aus dem Screen schon nicht näher erkennbar.
Neo Fetch checkt nicht, ob es WSL ist. Weiß ich nicht, kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen.
WSL hätte kein GUI, das ist, das ist kein, du siehst hier keine Linux Software, wenn es ein Windows ist.
Der hat dieses Standard Windows Terminal, das neue und da drin hat er WSL laufen. Das hier, das hier ist wahrscheinlich schlicht und ergreifend. Also vom Font Rendering und alles.
Also vom Font Rendering könnte ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen, dass das wirklich Windows ist. Aber gut, er kann uns auch einfach alle G-Baiten.
Was das für eine Grafikkarte ist? Microsoft Corporation Device, ja vielleicht ist es ja, keine Ahnung, VM oder WSL, WSL zeigt die Grafikkarten so an, keine Ahnung.
Weil das ist ja Hyper-V unter WSL 2, deswegen. So jetzt haben wir nochmal Shryker. Nee, das ist ein Bild von seinem Steam, das müssen wir nicht zeigen.
Jetzt haben wir Mika, Mika am Start mit einem sehr KappaPride mäßigem Desktop am Start. Alles einmal durch Lollcat gepiped.
Ich muss aber sagen, Arch by the way, was sonst? Ich muss aber sagen, ich finde das recht hübsch.
Ich hätte keinen Bock mir das den ganzen Tag zu geben, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Aber so für den reinen Flex finde ich ganz hübsch.
Also gucken wir uns mal an, es ist KDE, es sind Candy Icons, Candy Icons sind das, aber auch in der VM, ja es ist in der VM, eindeutig in der VM, auch hier oben.
Candy Icons, soll ich die mal kurz installieren, wollen wir uns die auch mal angucken? 10 Minuten Zeit haben wir noch.
Candy Icons, Candy Icons Shit. Aber wir gucken uns mal Candy Icons an.
Komm mal, ein Grill hat die Icons designt, Designer Grill, also Candy Icons, ok die Dinger sehen wirklich so.
Wobei die bei dem ja noch farbenfroher aussehen, aber gar nicht mal so bad. Gar nicht mal so bad, also ich muss sagen das andere gefällt mir jetzt zwar persönlich besser, aber gar nicht so mies.
Candy Icons, heute gar nicht mal so mies oder? Ist doch schon, also wenn man den Style mag, ist doch, ok mal gucken wie die oben rechts aussehen.
Ah der hat dafür keine Icons, ok na das ist natürlich doof. Aber das FireFox Icon gefällt mir schon mal gar nicht. Aber für das Terminal hat er was eigenes.
Ja ich gebe zu, so richtig mein Geschmack trifft es jetzt nicht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht. Es sieht deutlich besser aus als ich es mir vorgestellt habe.
Ich überliebe das wieder, ja wenn man sein gesamter Theme darauf abstimmt dann Grill by the way, ok ne ist ein Typ.
Ach Lara ist der Nachname, ja dann dachte ich der Vorname, deswegen habe ich gedacht Designer Grill am Start.
Aber insgesamt so die Kombination, bei ihm passt das tatsächlich ganz gut. Mir persönlich wäre das Terminal etwas zu transparent, zu wenig Kontrast bei der Schrift.
Aber hat ja jeder so seinen eigenen Geschmack was das angeht.
Das hier unten muss ich sagen finde ich tatsächlich ganz schick, da passen die Icons auch gut dabei. Aber das passt wirklich nur in diesem Gesamtkontext ganz gut.
Jetzt haben wir als nächstes Flix sein Desktop, aber schön gemacht hat er es finde ich auch.
Flix KDE Plasma Papyrus Dark Icons, die hatte ich auch mal eine Weile.
Arch Linux, ihr habt so viel Zeug immer installiert, so viele Packages komme ich überhaupt nicht.
Das ist eine coole Schriftart, das ist der Mac OS Font.
MeSlo ist der Mac OS Font, ich glaube bei Mac OS heißt der Mainlo, aber das ist der Mac OS Font.
Das da hinten steht für Dotted Zero, also dass die 0 einen Punkt in der Mitte hat, hier bin ich mir nicht sicher, das eine ist die Größe und das andere ist auch eine spezielle Variante von dem Font.
DZ ist die Variante des Fonts mit einem Dotted Zero, also 0 mit einem Punkt in der Mitte. Schöner Font, würde ich auch benutzen wenn ich nicht schon Hack hätte.
Moment, ShareX gibt es für Linux? Nein oder? Das bestimmt über Wine. Ja ja hier, das ist Wine.
Warum macht man jetzt Screenshot? Kann ShareX unter Linux auch GIFs machen über Wine? Das wäre dann schon Sixhead Time.
Wobei ich FireShot mag was Screenshots angeht. Leider kann FireShot keine GIFs, das wäre noch cool.
Man kann im Zweifelsfall natürlich immer OBS machen und Captchern, aber ja. Guck mal es gibt Leute die verwenden noch Pidgin.
Habe ich auch schon 20 Jahre oder so nicht mehr verwendet gefühlt. Ich glaube das letzte Mal Pidgin aber ohne Scheiß habe ich wahrscheinlich vor über 10 Jahren zuletzt verwendet.
Wenn das mal reicht, wenn nicht noch länger her. Twinko verwendet man den Hackerkreis noch Pidgin? Ja wahrscheinlich mit OTR.
OTA? Wie hieß das? OTM? Keine Ahnung, diesem Pidgin Verschlüsselungsding.
OTR, doch OTR. FFmpeg ist das einzige was man... Ja mit FFmpeg ist es halt ein bisschen doof irgendwie einen Bildschirmbereich auszuschneiden.
Ich meine, du kannst bestimmt... Also FFmpeg kann glaube ich Native X-Sessions Captchern, das geht, aber du musst ja dann quasi den Offset irgendwie einstellen, Worra Captchern und so.
Da bist du ja 3 Stunden mit beschäftigt. Oder du hast irgendwie so einen Screencrapper dafür, dann pipes du irgendwie die Koordinaten nach FFmpeg oder irgendwas ganz Wirres.
Ja. So. Klingt nach einem Streamprojekt? Nein, nein, ich baue kein weiteres Screenshot Tool, das überlasse ich anderen.
Da gibt es schon tausende von. So. Dann haben wir noch 2 Stück. Wir haben als nächstes den Desktop von Yali. Also Yali Desktop am Start.
Wäre für meinen Geschmack auch zu wenig Kontrast für den Text? Der Text, Alter. Placingly fast written in Rust, was sonst?
Also. Es wäre mir ein bisschen wenig Kontrast für der Schrift und zu einem transparenten Hintergrund. Ist das so mein Projekt fertig? Nee, noch nicht mal so richtig weiter implementiert, die ganzen Sachen.
Nee, nee. Müssten wir wirklich fertig. Wir müssen so viel Zeug noch fertig machen. Das ist Endeavor OS, auch Arch, by the way. Virtual Box, MonkaS, Alter, habe ich ja noch ewig nicht mal gesehen, dass einer Virtual Box verwendet.
Was für ein Domain Projekt? Wir haben einen Prometheus Check, einen Prometheus Exporter entwickelt, der sich bei unterschiedlichen Domain Registraren einloggen kann und dort die Restlaufzeit von Domains abfragen.
Aktuell unterstützt ist, glaube ich, Cloudflare und Namecheap, NameSilo, ja so vier, fünf Anbieter unterstützt das aktuell.
Rest habe ich noch nicht eingebaut, aber ich habe ich habe jetzt auch nicht mal weiter weiter dran gebaut.
Du hast das für Domain, Discount und Netcap. Was benutzt du oder irgendwie selbst was selbst du hast gescript dort?
Also was du zum Checken benutzt?
Wie gesagt, wir können alle möglichen Anbieter noch implementieren. Das hat sich bis jetzt noch nicht ergeben. Außer bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, ob der Architektur Ansatz, wie wir es gemacht haben, mit den Kommandoszeilen Parametern so sinnig ist.
Ich habe die kleinen Go gebaut und dann auch als Prometheus Exporter. Ja klar, wenn man nur zwei, drei Anbieter unterstützen will, ist das so was relativ schnell selbst gebaut. Ich hatte halt vorher, ich baue quasi einen erweiterbaren Prometheus Exporter mit allen möglichen Anbietern und haue das dann auf GitHub.
Vielleicht hatte da der eine oder andere Interesse dran, aber bis jetzt hatte ich keinen Bock weiter zu machen. Wir haben im Stream da mal angefangen, lief ja auch, lief ja auch, hat ja auch funktioniert.
Aber das Schwierige ist ja die ganzen Anbieter zu unterstützen.
So, also gucken wir uns mal noch weiter den Desktop von ihm. Also er programmiert Rust, selbst natürlich in Vim, so wie sich das gehört, weil warum Blazingly Fast in Rust, wenn man nicht auch Blazingly Fast beim Editieren ist. Dann haben wir am Start Endeavor OS, Arch, by the way, wenn auch nur über Bande Arch.
Xfce Terminal. Okay, das ist natürlich auch selten. Also sehe ich selten Leute Xfce Terminal verwenden, aber wisst ihr, was mir daran sieht?
Das ist eines der riesen Vorteile von Linux oder eines der wirklich coolen Sachen von von Linux. Du kannst einfach das verwenden, was du willst und das zusammen mit was anderem, wie es dir am besten gefällt.
Du musst dir da keine großartigen Gedanken machen, ob es geht, es geht einfach.
Ich bin, ich bin gleich oft nicht mehr lange. Und du hast dann auch eine riesen Auswahl, außer, außer das, wo du nichts zur Auswahl hast.
Nee, per Whois kannst du nicht abfragen. Also manche Domains kannst du per Whois abfragen, aber viele kannst du nicht abfragen. Versuche mal das.de Domain über Whois abzufragen.
So, dann, was fällt mir da dran noch auf? Also es ist mir ein bisschen wenig Kontrast, mehr sieht man ja leider nicht.
Es ist, es scheint mir ein i3 zu sein, oder? Ja, es ist ein i3, schon mal nice. Das da oben ist von VirtualBox, die hat eine schöne, er hat eine hübsche Leiste.
Frag mich, was das ist. Ist das Polybar? Was hat er denn da oben?
Ist das nicht die Vorold? Nee, es ist die 3. Es ist ziemlich sicher, es steht hier, steht hier. Aber es ist, es ist in der VM. Icons sind Kyogia Icons. Wir sehen hier keine Icons, aber wir können mal Kyogia Icons, wir können mal gucken, wie die Dinger aussehen.
Kyogia Icons sieben. Okay, Kyogia. Ist das das, was Dings verwendet, was elementary OS verwendet? Das sieht sehr ähnlich aus.
Nee, mein Geschmack trifft es auch nicht so nahe, es sieht sehr ähnlich aus zu, eh anscheinend nicht.
Ansonsten erkennt man nicht viel. Mein Geschmack wäre die Farbgebung ehrlich gesagt auch nicht und der Kontrast ist mir auch nicht im Terminal richtig da, aber hat ja jeder unterschiedlichen Geschmack. Die Leiste finde ich aber hübsch.
Die Leiste finde ich cool. Android Emulator unter Linux ist ein bisschen Pain's Champ. Was ganz gut geht, wenn man einfach nur mal was ausprobieren will, ist der offizielle Android Studio Emulator, der klappt. Aber da machst du natürlich auch keine großen Sprünge.
So und das ist der letzte Desktop von Slackware 33, der war vorhin auch im Stream. Also zumindest kommt mir der Namen bekannt vor.
So, also gucken wir uns mal an. Was haben wir hier, eine i3? Glücklicherweise eine i3 nicht mit Standard-Leiste. Hast du auch Bumblebee-Status? Sieht sehr ähnlich aus, erinnert mich ein bisschen an meine Leiste.
Erinnert mich ein bisschen an meine Status-Leiste, nur mit anderem Farb-Theme. Ja und ein bisschen andere Blocks drin. Aber im Großen und Ganzen allein schon durch diese Load-Anzeige sieht relativ wenig aus.
Aber du hast das Kalendermodul noch dabei. Habe ich jetzt keinen großartigen Sinn drin gesehen. Okay, das ist auch selten. Warum hast du bei deinem i3 noch die, wie nennt sich das, Titelbar?
Hat das einen Sinn? Also wachst du damit irgendwas oder dass du besser erkennst, was was ist? Screenfetch hat diesen Fehler schon ewig.
Okay, du hast so gelassen. Aber du hast leichte Gaps, da kann das wenigstens gut unterscheiden. Ich habe die Titelbar schon eine ganze Weile aus.
Ansonsten muss ich ehrlich sagen, der Font erinnert mich irgendwie an Windows. Was ist denn das für ein Font? Ist das Konsolas oder sowas? Was ist das für ein Font?
Die Fenster siehst du so besser, das ist auf jeden Fall. Aus Nerdfonds, ja aus Nerdfonds gibt es ja jede Menge. Das sieht sehr Windows-Font-mäßig aus.
Könnte Konsolas sein. Ja gut, aber deine GPU ist LLVM-Pipe. Okay, ist das der, was soll uns das sagen?
Ist das die Anzeige für den AMD-Treiber oder? Ah, das ist eine VM. Und was ist LLVM-Pipe? Kann man da irgendwie ein bisschen GPU packen?
Ach, das ist der Grab. Okay, das habe ich schon mal gehört. Da kannst du ein bisschen Acceleration machen in der VM. Klappt das gut?
Ist das, taugt das, ist das besser als die VM-Ware? Acceleration? Ich meine, das ist ja ein Linux-ONI-Ding. Und Linux unter Linux-ONI würde mich mal interessieren, wie gut das funktioniert.
Gut, das VM, allerdings das VM-Theme passt überhaupt nicht zum Rest. Ich finde, der VM sieht komplett deplatziert drin aus. Und außerdem sind ja die Rahmen auch viel zu groß drum. Verschwendet ja total viel Platz.
Aber schicke Status-Leiste. Poggle, Leute. Exzellent.
Dann machen wir das nächste Mal mit dem Sarix weiter. Da hat gerade was gepostet. Gucken wir uns das nächste Mal an, dann haben wir auch was.
Wir sehen uns, Leute. Ich gehe jetzt pennen. Bis die Tage. Wahrscheinlich bis morgen. Macht's gut. See you.